Nein, nein. Zahlen, zahlen, zahlen in der Musik und das heißt, es ist der letzte Donnerstag im Monat und das heißt, es ist wieder mal Zeit fürs Chaosradio. Der Blue Moon, einmal im Monat, wo der Chaos Computer Club sich im Studio einschließt, ganz viel Unsinn treibt und möglicherweise nebenbei auch noch ein spannendes technisches Thema erklärt. Heute zu Gast unter anderem der Herr Starbuck, hallo und guten Abend.
Schönen guten Abend.
Und Frau Doktor Konstanze Kurz, hallo und guten Abend.
Hallo.
Und manchmal ist es ja so, dass im Chaosradio über ein Thema gesprochen wird, das von weit herkommt, wo man gar nicht wusste, dass es gibt. Heute habt ihr möglicherweise unter Umständen schon mal irgendwo irgendwas drüber gehört. Wir sprechen heute über Biometrie. Oder über eine Darreichungsform, die wirklich jeder verstanden hat, nämlich der Fingerabdruckscanner des neuen iPhones ist gehackt worden. Und was diese beiden Sachen miteinander zu tun haben, also einerseits die Diskussion um die Verwendung von Körpermerkmalen in digitalen Bereichen und andererseits, die ein Lifestyleprodukt wurde, ich nenne es jetzt mal kaputt gemacht oder kaputt gespielt, das klären wir heute hier in der Sendung. Also einerseits, wie macht man das überhaupt? Weil es klingt ja so, also viele Leute denken, es ist total kompliziert. Andere denken, es ist total einfach. Wir erklären heute so ein Mittelding. Und andererseits sozusagen, was macht das eigentlich mit unserer Gesellschaft und wie läuft die Kommunikation drüber ab? Weil das konnte man an dem Beispiel gerade sehr, sehr, sehr gut beobachten. Also kurze Abfolge, erst der Hack selber, dann die Folgen. Und das sind die nächsten zwei Stunden. Ihr könnt währenddessen auch gerne anrufen, wenn ihr wollt, wenn ihr zum Thema was beitragen wollt oder wenn ihr irgendwo einen Punkt habt, wo ihr denkt, das hab ich jetzt nicht so ganz genau verstanden. Vielleicht könnte man das noch mal besser erklären. Die Telefonnummer dazu ist 0331 70 97 110. Und wir fangen jetzt hier an. Starbucks ist nämlich nicht nur Starbucks, sondern Starbucks ist auch bekannt als der Typ, der das iPhone kaputt gemacht hat. Und das ist ja nicht, also ich muss mal despakitisch ausdrücken, das ist ja nichts Neues, was er da gemacht hat, sondern die Technik, die er gemacht hat, die ist schon Jahre alt und es ist quasi nur eine handwerklich perfektionierte Anwendung dieser Technik. Wenn ich das richtig sage oder springst du mir jetzt ins Gesicht?
Ne, ne, ne, das ist schon. Also es ist tatsächlich nicht mehr wirklich perfektioniert, also die Auflösung hat ein bisschen hochgesetzt worden, das ist irgendwie alles.
Okay, also sagen sie es ist eine genaue Ausführung der Anleitung, die er eigentlich hatte.
Nur ein bisschen ordentlicher gearbeitet.
Genau, und wir klären aber heute hier einmal von Anfang an, wie macht man das eigentlich, so ein Fingerabdruck nachbauen?
Also, ich würde am besten mal anfangen, die ganze Geschichte von vorne. Und zwar, das iPhone kam natürlich raus und sofort haben sich alle Leute drauf gestürzt und wollten es kaufen. Das heißt, die erste große Schwierigkeit war, erst mal an ein iPhone selber zu kommen. Ja, Dennis zum Beispiel, also ich habe am Freitag rausgekommen, am Donnerstagabend noch mit jemandem aus dem Club geredet, der meinte, er will sich auch auf jeden Fall eins kaufen. Und habe ihm noch so Geld in die Hand gedrückt und meinte, ja dann Freitag schön die Schlange stellen. Er meinte, er macht durch. Steht sich gleich früh um acht in die Schlange und holt eins. Dann lese ich, als ich aufgewacht bin nur, da waren 1000 Leute, ich bin wieder ins Bett gegangen. Also da war schon mal dahin mit, irgendwie gleich ein Zahm zum Spielen. Aber glücklicherweise hat Heise sich bereit erklärt, mir eins zur Verfügung zu stellen. Die haben sich dann in Hamburg in die Schlange gestellt und mir das geschickt. Das heißt, das kam dann tatsächlich Samstag Mittag, irgendwie so kurz vor zwölf, lag es in meinem Briefkasten. Und da dachte ich mir schön, jetzt erst mal gleich loslegen, pack es aus, schalte es an und dann wollte es erst mal eine SIM-Karte haben, bevor man loslegen kann. Das heißt, da war ich schon mal irgendwie echt aufgeschmissen. Und zwar glücklicherweise nicht Sonntag, sondern Samstag. Das heißt, man konnte noch in die Läden gehen, bin ich erst mal losgerannt.
Also so eine kleine SIM-Karte.
Genau, also ich dachte, ich gehe davon aus, es ist ein Micro-SIM. Also ich wusste, es ist keine normale SIM. Und ich habe irgendwie echt nur so uraltelefone, wo halt noch normale SIMs reinkommen. Da dachte ich mir, dann gehe ich in den Laden, frage nach einer Micro-SIM, wird schon passen. Komm nach Hause, mach das iPhone dann erst wirklich auf und sehen, die Micro-SIM passt gar nicht. Ich hab dann irgendwie diesen Adapter rausgezogen, versucht die SIM-Karte reinzustecken, und es hat irgendwie nicht gepasst. Und dann habe ich nachgelesen und es ist eine Nano-SIM gewesen.
Wir bemerken also an dieser Stelle erstens, Hacker sind auch nur Menschen. Und zweitens, manchmal sind es die ganz praktischen Probleme, die einen davon abhalten, eine Technik zu erforschen.
Genau, also das waren auf jeden Fall so die zwei großen Schwierigkeiten mit diesem ganzen Hack eigentlich. Also erst mal an dieses Telefon zu kommen und zweitens irgendwie diese Micro-SIM-Karte, eine Nano-SIM-Karte zu verwandeln, um sie dabei zu kaputt zu machen. Also glücklicherweise war da gerade ein Sonderangebot, das heißt, sie haben mir zwei SIM-Karten für einen Preis gegeben. Das heißt, ich war beruhigt, dass ich irgendwie hätte eine kaputt machen können. Aber die erste hat dann tatsächlich, also sie war zwar total wackelig, aber sie hat tatsächlich dann auch funktioniert.
Ja, eigentlich geht die Geschichte ein bisschen früher los, weil schon als die Veröffentlichung war und Apple ja auch eine Menge Werbung gemacht hat mit diesem Fingerabdruckscanner, da war schon sofort die Rede davon. Da muss man aber genauer angucken. Also die die Story beginnt eigentlich ein bisschen früher, aber als dann klar war, an welchem Tag das hier in Deutschland verkauft wird, da sollte es möglichst schnell gehen, weil war auch schon klar, dass sich andere daran machen und man wollte ja nicht der Letzte sein, der den Fingerabdruckscanner da.
Also eigentlich wollte man der Erste sein. Also nee, tatsächlich irgendwie, also wann war die Vorstellung irgendwann im August, im Mitte August oder so was?
Ich weiß gar nicht genau.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall schon ein paar Wochen her gewesen und danach irgendwie natürlich erstmal, oh cool, die machen jetzt tatsächlich Fingerabdruck rein und hat man natürlich erstmal versucht, die passenden Dokumente zu finden. Und tatsächlich hab ich irgendwie auch in einem Interview gesagt, ich hab halt tatsächlich mehr Zeit damit verbracht, nach Dokumenten zu suchen, was denn dieser Scanner jetzt genau tut, als nachher wirklich für den Hack nachher zu brauchen.
Ja, dem liegt natürlich zu Grunde, dass die Annahme, dass es schwieriger würde, also weil ja auch die Ankündigung war, dass das eben ein sehr technisch anspruchsvoller Sensor sei. Also die Annahme steht ja dahinter, da sollte man wohl erst mal die technischen Spezifikationen lesen und sich nicht nur an das Gerät und die Funktionalität machen. Deswegen war die Suche vorher so.
Also das ist halt so, dass normale rangehen. Zumindest bei mir, wenn ich halt irgendwie einen Hack vorbereite, dann sucht man sich natürlich erst mal alle Informationen dazu, um halt erst mal so die Sachen einzugrenzen, was man probieren kann, was man nicht probieren braucht. Aber wie gesagt, das war halt nahezu unmöglich. Ich hab ein einziges Bild gefunden, was halt so grob beschrieben hat, dass da irgendwie ein Array ist, wo halt ein HF-Feld ausgesendet wird.
Halt! So, ich würde ja gerne, ich hätte ja gerne sagen, dass wir diese Sendung nicht nur das iPhone erklären, sondern generell auch für alle Leute, die es vielleicht noch gar nicht gehört haben, dieses ganze Biometrie-Ding. Deswegen an dieser Stelle vielleicht ein kleiner Ausflug. Was macht genau eigentlich ein Fingerabdruckscanner?
Also Fingerabdruckscanner scannt, wie der Name so schön sagt, Fingerabdrücke. Von daher ist das, was zumindest Apple proklamiert hat, was der Sensor tut, eigentlich gar kein Fingerabdruckscanner, sondern ein Fingersensor, weil sie ja behaupten, nicht den Fingerabdruck zu nehmen, sondern halt subtermal.
Unter der Haut.
Also die unteren Hautschichten aufzunehmen.
Also das heißt nicht nur quasi ein Foto von dem Finger zu machen, sondern auch noch irgendwie die Hautschichten drunter zu vermessen.
Die Sensoren bisher sind entweder optisch oder kapazitiv. Das heißt entweder wirklich ein Foto von dem Finger abdrucken, oder kapazitiv praktisch das Feld, also die Kapazitätsänderung, die der Finger bzw. also du hast ja Hautrillen, die halt den Fingerabdruck bilden und je nachdem ob entweder Luft, also in der Rille praktisch über den Sensor fällt es, oder halt die Haut direkt aufliegt, hast du unterschiedliche Kapazitäten. Und daraus wird dann halt ein Bild generiert. Und was Apple jetzt behauptet hat, ist, dass sie halt nicht auf diese Sachen gucken, sondern mit einem Frequenzfeld in den Finger reinleuchten sozusagen, also Hochfrequenz und praktisch tiefer liegende Hautschichten analysieren.
Also nur ganz grobes Bild, so was wie ein Röntgenbild oder Computer-Tomographie?
Es ist eher so was wie Ultraschall. Also wenn du halt so kennst, wie du hast halt ein Feld, was du halt reinschickst und die Reflektion misst du dann und daraus kannst du halt auch ein Bild generieren.
Das ist auch nicht so neu, so eine Sensoren gibt es natürlich auch anderswo. Also das hat Apple jetzt nicht erfunden.
Ich höre trotzdem zum ersten Mal davon.
Also der Vorteil davon ist natürlich einerseits, dass du halt mit verschmutzten Fingern und sowas weniger Probleme hast, weil du halt wirklich nicht das Bild nimmst, sondern halt tiefere Hautschichten. Du hast weniger Veränderungen, also irgendwie so Schnitte an der Oberfläche sollten sich nicht so stark auswirken.
Auch so sehr fettige, also wer zum Beispiel ziemlich geschwitzt oder wenn es Sommer ist.
Oder halt der eigentlich sehr große oder der innovative Vorteil, wo ich auch stark damit gerecht habe, dass das tatsächlich der Fall sein wird, dass halt Latenzabdrücke, also wenn du halt ein Glas anfasst, hast du halt Fett dran, was sich dann halt auf dem Glas rückstände bildet, wo du halt praktisch deinen Fingerabdruck am Glas hinterlässt. Und was ich halt dachte, dass dadurch, dass sie halt in die tieferen Hautschichten gehen, hast du halt andere Bilder als die, die du halt wirklich hinterlässt. Das heißt, das wäre eigentlich so, dachte ich, die große Hürde bei diesem Fingerabdrucksensor, dass man halt wirklich aus dem eigentlichen Bild, was man halt irgendwie auf dem Display oder auf ein Glas Bier hinterlässt, nicht den Abdruck rekonstruieren kann, der tatsächlich das iPhone freischaltet.
Okay, und das ist ja das, was du sozusagen vorher schon gemacht hast. Also diese, die, wir bauen uns einen Fingerabdruck nach, das gibt es ja schon länger vom Club. Und hast du dann also gedacht, das wird überhaupt gar nicht funktionieren, oder hast du dann einfach den ganz normalen Arbeitsgang angefangen?
Also mir war einfach klar, dass es früher oder später funktionieren wird, weil halt kein System oder kein Sicherheitssystem ist unknackbar. Und bei Biometrie ist das halt nochmal, ist die Aussage halt nochmal viel zutreffender, weil du halt dort einfach eine gewisse Toleranz per se, also durch das System selber hast. Das heißt irgendwie dann, es gibt, es wird eine Möglichkeit geben, das System zu überwinden. Da war halt die Frage, wo kommt man oder wie kommt man an die Merkmale ran? Und halt da wäre halt so der, also wenn das halt nicht geklappt hätte, also ich hatte mir halt wirklich schon so mit ein paar Kumpels Gedanken gemacht, dass man halt wirklich den Sensor direkt irgendwie anzapft, die Bilder, die dort direkt aufgenommen werden, analysiert und dann halt gucken kann, wie ist das Bild von dem realen Finger, wie ist das Bild, wenn ich jetzt in der Trappe auflege, wo ist der Unterschied, was muss man vielleicht noch anpassen? Also damit habe ich wirklich stark gerechnet. Ich habe halt auch so grob gesagt, ich denke mal eine Woche, ein bis zwei Wochen werde ich da schon dran sitzen. Also das war halt einfach so.
Also man hätte vielleicht auch eine neue Methode erfinden müssen. Es war einfach nicht klar, dass man die alten Methoden noch mal probieren kann und dass sie funktionieren. Sondern also der Spaß daran ist ja, aus sich zu überlegen, was kann man vielleicht noch erfinden? Insofern war da etwas Enttäuschung.
Ich habe mir tatsächlich irgendwie einen Tag vorher wirklich so eine Liste gemacht, irgendwie was man alles probiert oder zumindest erstmal zum Beispiel, was nicht erkannt wird, welche Materialien erkannt werden, was man halt noch so tun kann. Ich habe auf dem Rückweg von der SIM-Kartenkauf bin ich durch eine Gartenanlage gelaufen, habe halt irgendwie diverse Blätter und Blüten und eine Pflaume eingesammelt, weil ich halt einfach Material haben wollte, was ich rauflege, um zu gucken, wie der Sensor darauf reagiert. Also kann man solche Sachen einlernen, erkennt der Sensor das überhaupt als fingerähnliches Ding?
Also das ist ein wichtiger Punkt. Beim Fingerabdruckfälschen, sage ich jetzt mal, geht es nicht nur darum, das Bild sozusagen nachzubauen, sondern der Sensor ist noch offen in irgendeiner anderen Art und Weise, meistens in der Lage zu erkennen, ob das jetzt ein richtiger Finger ist oder ein Stück Holz.
Genau, also du musst halt hautähnliche Eigenschaften haben. Und irgendwie, das war, dachte ich, eigentlich so die große Herausforderung, tatsächlich erstmal ein Material zu finden. Also dass man einen Abdruck einer Trappe bauen kann, die halt genauso wie ein Finger aussieht, das ist eigentlich relativ selbstverständlich. Das kriegt man hin mit Techniken.
Ja, du sagst es so, aber das müssen wir auch nochmal genauer lernen, wie es geht.
Wenn man sich ein bisschen damit beschäftigt, dann weiß man, dass es irgendwie geht. Also da hatte ich auch noch ganz andere Ideen, die ich jetzt nicht verraten werde, die kommt dann halt später, wenn sie tatsächlich mal neue Sensoren schaffen. Aber ist hier alles nicht der Fall gewesen.
Also es gibt natürlich eine gewisse Routine bei den Verfahren, die, ich meine, das ist neun, acht Jahre alt. Und wir haben das auch relativ häufig durchgeführt. Es gibt sogar Workshops, die wir über die Jahre gemacht haben.
Aber können wir das dann einfach genau mal erzählen? Also genau dieses Ding, wie baut man eigentlich einen Fingerabdruck?
Nach der alten Methode? Noch ganz kurz, also wie ich dann halt tatsächlich angefangen hab, weil es halt am einfachsten war. Ich hab halt meinen Finger genommen, hab den in Wachs abgegossen, also halt meinen Fingerabdruck in Wachs gemacht, hab dann halt das Standardmaterial, was ich immer benutze, das ist irgendwie Holzleim, war jetzt irgendwie halt billig, irgendwie trocknet relativ schnell aus und hat halt irgendwie wirklich auch sehr gute Eigenschaften. Hab halt irgendwie das Material genommen, hab das halt in die Altreppe, also in diesen Abdruck reingegossen, hab's austrocknen lassen, hab's rauf gelegt und das hat entsperrt und ich war erst mal so...
Halt, noch mal von vorne. Du hast deinen Finger genommen, hast ihn in warmes Wachs gedrückt, hast dann natürlich einen Fingerabdruck in Wachs gehabt, hast da rein wiederum Holzkleim. Die Form war aus Wachs, also negativ von deinem Fingerabdruck gehabt, hast da den Holzkaltleim reingegossen. Du hast es aber nicht so richtig dick gemacht, sondern so dünn, dass du es dann noch irgendwie...
Ich hab's auch dick gemacht, also dünn und dick. Also das ist dann halt so, wie das vorgehen. Also du machst halt dünne Attrappen, weil du halt eventuell denkst, dass dahinter liegende Finger doch noch irgendwie erkannt werden muss. Du machst dicke Attrappen, um halt genau das auszuschließen. Also ist halt so, dass dann wissenschaftliche Rangehen dabei.
Also mach ganz dünne für den Fall, dass der Sensor noch guckt und da irgendwie Menschenfleisch sehen will, dann kann er sozusagen, sieht er das, oder ganz dick, falls es egal ist. Und dann hast du einfach diesen Holzkaltlein-Pröppel auf den Sensor und dann ging das auf. Entschuldigung, es ist 22.17 Uhr, was machen wir den Rest der Sendung?
Naja, das wär nicht der Hack. Also das, was man halt eigentlich haben will, ist tatsächlich von einem Bild, also von einem Fingerabdruck, also ein Latenzabdruck, also das, was man halt auf einem Glasscheibe hinterlässt, daraus dann irgendwie die Attrappe zu bauen.
Ich dachte tatsächlich, die sagen selbst, das ist komplizierter. Also ich dachte tatsächlich, dass die eigentliche Attrappe die man hat, dass die ein bisschen aufwändiger gebaut wird. Also irgendwie hauchdünn und...
Hätte ich, also gerade, weil sie halt von Subthermal geredet haben, hab ich auch schon damit gerechnet, dass ich eine Zweischichtattrappe brauchen muss. Also war halt bis jetzt auch nicht der Fall gewesen, aber das war halt so die Idee, wenn sie halt tiefere Hauttichten machen, dann macht man halt irgendwie einfach eine Attrappe, die aus Zweiertrappen besteht, die man aufeinanderklebt. Das wäre halt so der nächste Schritt gewesen, aber auch das alles nicht.
So, und jetzt für den richtigen Angriff ist es natürlich so, Frau Dr. Kotz schüttelt die ganze Zeit den Kopf.
Ich sag das doch nicht immer. Also nur nochmal, um sie klar zu machen. Den Anfangstest, den Starbuck gemacht hat, der dient natürlich auch erstmal nur, um selber rauszufinden, ob diese Art der Attrappe geht. Aber dass man natürlich selten von jemandem, wo man jetzt ein fremdes iPhone hätte und den Abdruck überwinden will, da hat man ja nun in der Regel einfach niemand.
Das ist schon klar, aber es ist trotzdem ein bisschen erschütternd, dass das so einfach ist. Genau das hab ich auch gesehen. Stell dir mal vor, du hast einen übellaunigen Freund, man sitzt halt im Wohnzimmer, man kennt das ja irgendwie, man sitzt lange zusammen und fängt an, an Kerzen rumzuprökeln und einfach auf dem Tisch stehen.
Ich weiß nicht, was du für bizarre Hobbys hast.
Das ist kein bizarres Hobby, wenn du ach Frau Doktor Kurz. Das passiert schon mal. Egal. So und jetzt ist aber natürlich genau der Punkt, wir wollen nicht sozusagen ganz unauffällig sagen, hier, du könntest mal kurz deinen Finger in das warme Wachs da vielleicht reindrücken, sondern das optimale ist ja, also das optimale Anflusszeichen für den Hack ist ja, ich finde ein iPhone, finde und nehme dann die Fingerabdrücke von dem iPhone. Das heißt, ich bin darauf angewiesen, dass das irgendwie angefasst wurde und dass ich daraus einen Fingerabdruck konstruiere. Das ist natürlich wahrscheinlich dann doch ein bisschen schwieriger als ein Wachs zu drücken.
Nicht viel, aber tatsächlich irgendwie. Zu dem Zeitpunkt dachte ich so, oh Scheiße, ich schaff's einfach nicht, weil das wird jeder Trottel machen können. Du wirst nicht der Erste sein. Genau, wenn ich tatsächlich gut vorbereitet wäre, wäre das iPhone einfach kaputt gewesen. Also eigentlich sogar nach fünf Minuten. Da ist erstmal richtig schlecht Laune gekriegt, weil wenn man so eine Herausforderung angeht, will man natürlich dann auch der Erste sein.
Man will aber auch irgendwie was Cooles abliefern. Man hat die Vorstellung, dass man daran auch ein bisschen zerforschen kann. Insofern war da Samstagabend die Enttäuschung doch groß.
Der nächste Schritt ist dann tatsächlich, was du gerade angedeutet hast. Du findest ein iPhone, du findest einen Fingerabdruck auf dem iPhone und machst aus diesem Fingerabdruck dann erstmal eine Form, um daraus dann wieder den Fingerabdruck zu gießen. Und das ist dann, was ich tatsächlich dann auch gemacht habe, was wir aber auch schon seit knapp zehn Jahren jetzt inzwischen machen. Also das Video ist tatsächlich, ich hab nochmal nachgeguckt von 2003, 2004, genau neun Jahre alt, wo wir damals mit Wetter noch das Video im Club gedreht haben. Und es hat sich tatsächlich auch einfach nix verändert an der Technologie.
Leute, seit zwanzig Minuten redet ihr von, wir machen immer genau dasselbe und das haben wir natürlich gemacht. Wir wollen jetzt mal wissen, wie das denn überhaupt funktioniert. Herrgott nochmal!
Okay, also erstens kann man sich das alles schön irgendwie im Video angucken.
Ja, wir sind jetzt aber hier im Radio.
Du nimmst dieses, also so wie ich es getan hab, ich hab das iPhone genommen, hab halt einfach mal einen Passcode eingetippt, um halt meinen Fingerabdruck auf dem Display vom iPhone zu haben. Hab dann das iPhone auf den Scanner gelegt, hab ein Bild von dem Fingerabdruck gemacht, der erstaunlicherweise super gut war. Also ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, woans lag, ob's an dem guten Scanner lag, den ich benutzt hab, oder ob die Oberfläche dieses Glas einfach so gute Eigenschaften hat. Also auf jeden Fall, normalerweise hab ich halt diesen Abdruck, also das eingescannte Bild, immer noch bearbeiten müssen.
Du hast tatsächlich sozusagen einfach nur auf dem Touchscreen...
Ich hab den Fettabdruck hinterlassen, dass einfach so, wie's war, umgedreht auf den Scanner gelegt, war der Bildschirm dann ausgescannt? Genau, ausgemacht, war dann wie ein schöner schwarzer Hintergrund, und das Bild war super. Das war so 1A top. Und ich hab halt wirklich, also normalerweise, wenn ich halt so Hacks mache, das erste Mal macht man halt schöne Abdrücke, man macht sich ein bisschen fett an die Finger, macht halt einen ganz sauen Abdruck, und ich hab halt wirklich nur so, wie man's wirklich benutzt, den Daumen als Passcode-Eingabe genommen, hab dieses Bild genommen, und das ging nachher auch. Genau, was der nächste Schritt, also du scannst das halt ein, und dann hast du halt so Sachen, wie du musstest das halt einmal invertieren, das heißt, du willst das nachher ätzen. Das ist irgendwie so der, also du machst die Form und aus einer Leiterplatte. Das heißt, du musst erst mal ein Bild haben, was du nachher irgendwie auf die Fotostruktur der Leiterplatte aufbringst.
Das heißt, wenn du das Bild gescannt hast, dann sind die Erhebungen sozusagen schwarz, und die Rillen sind durchsichtig auf dem Bild.
Also das ist ein graustufen Bild, und was du halt zum Ätzen haben willst, ist einfach ein schwarz-weiß Bild. Also du willst halt einfach entweder durchsichtig oder nicht durchsichtig haben. Das heißt, du machst erst einmal also mit einer Binarisierung, ich weiß nicht genau, wie es heißt, im Sprachgebrauch von den...
Photoshopern?
Photoshoppern.
Heute ist es praktisch in dem Bildbearbeitungsprogramm ein Klick, weil diese Invertierungsfunktion, die bieten heute alle...
Ich meine nicht das Invertieren, sondern du trennst halt die Graukanäle nach irgendwie in schwarz-weiß Kanäle auf. Ist ja auch egal, wie es heißt, auf jeden Fall... Geht auch per Knopfdruck heute.
Man schiebt halt so einen Slider hin und her.
Du schiebst den schwarz und den weißen Slider hin und her und dann hast du irgendwie halt ein gutes Bild. Invertierst du noch und dann druckst du es einfach aus auf eine Folie. Die Folie nimmt man dann... Also bei unserem ersten Hack, oder bei dem halt neun Jahre alten Hack, haben wir die Folie direkt genommen als Abformgrundlage. Weil halt, wenn du es mit einem Schwarz... Also mit einem Tinten, mit einem Laserdrucker ausdruckst, hast du halt diese Laserpartikel, die sich natürlich auch zu einer gewissen... Genau, zu einer gewissen 3D-Struktur anordnen.
Und dann habt ihr es auf eine Folie drauf gedruckt. Also den investierten Fingerabdruck auf eine Folie drucken? Okay.
Und was wir halt früher gemacht haben, ist tatsächlich auch diesen Abdruck als Form genommen, dort den Halsheim rauf gemacht, abtrocknen lassen, abgezogen und dann die Attrappe schon fertig gewesen. Das heißt, du hast...
Das ist viel zu einfach.
Genau, das ist viel zu einfach. Also ich stand dann tatsächlich am Samstagabend irgendwie noch eine Stunde im Copyshop, weil ich halt dachte, hochauflösender Druck braucht man. Und dann hatten die zwar ganz groß Färbung dran, dass sie hier 2.400 DPI-Drucker haben, aber dieser scheiß Druckertreiber konnte immer nur mit 600 DPI ausdrucken. Und ich stand da echt so rum, ich hab wirklich eine halbe Stunde an diesen Einstellungen rumgepfuscht und hab gedacht, irgendwie muss das doch gehen. Hab dann irgendwann aufgegeben und es zu Hause nochmal probiert. Hab dann tatsächlich irgendwie es einfach ausgedruckt mit 600 DPI, dachte, naja, versuchen kann man's ja mal. Hab halt mal ne Form gemacht. Und das war dann Samstagabend so gegen 12 oder so was. Und hab die dann abgezogen und raufgelegt. Und ging nicht, ging nicht, ging nicht. Naja, gut, war eigentlich klar, dass es so nicht gehen kann. Muss man weiter probieren. Dann hab ich halt irgendwie nochmal gemacht, weil irgendwie, naja, ich konnte halt jetzt, also dieses Leiterplattenätzen war halt für den Abend einfach nicht mehr drin. Und hab's dann einfach so nachts irgendwie so. Ich lag im Bett, konnte irgendwie nicht pennen, nochmal aufgestanden, nochmal probiert. Und dann irgendwann ging's plötzlich. Und es ging einmal, dann ging's wieder ganz lange nicht. Da hab ich irgendwie nochmal ne andere Trappe genommen. Nochmal, dann hab ich's irgendwie so hinkriegt, dass es reproduzierbar war. Also tatsächlich den Abdruck von der Folie. Hab dann irgendwie Frank angerufen, der irgendwie noch wach war. Frank, ich hab's geschafft, wir müssen jetzt ein Video drehen. Dann meinte er, ja komm vorbei, ich bin im Club. Bin ich in Club gefahren. Ich stand in der Wohnung, hab gedacht, was muss ich mitnehmen für den Videodreh? Irgendwie Holzleim, die Folie, alles eingepackt. Stand in der Tür, hat nochmal überlegt, okay, ich hab alles dabei. Fahr in Club und dann so, und wo ist jetzt das iPhone? Und ich so, nein! Ich hab tatsächlich das iPhone zu Hause auf dem Tisch liegen lassen. Das war so viel der Fail.
Der Ball ging ja auch der Wind schon los. Weil Frank hat natürlich auch anderen Bescheid gesagt, dass wir uns jetzt mal um die Öffentlichkeitsarbeit kümmern müssen, wir müssen was schreiben.
Das konnte man auf Twitter lesen, Frank Rieger hat ja getwittert, ein Vögelchen hätte ihm geklöstert, das möglicherweise das Wochenende und so weiter.
Ja, er konnte sich wohl vor der Freude nicht zurückhalten.
Also tatsächlich war der erste erfolgreiche Hack tatsächlich schon am Samstag Nacht. Aber das Wald so, es war einfach nicht reproduzierbar.
Aber hast du rausgefunden, woran das lag? Dass es manchmal ging, manchmal nicht?
Also es lag auf jeden Fall an der zu... Also im Gegensatz zu geätzter Leiterplatte, wo du halt ungefähr so eine 70 µKupferschicht hast, die du dann halt irgendwie auffüllst, hast du dort halt so was wie 10 µ, die die Tonapartikel angeordnet sind. Das heißt, es ist einfach deutlich weniger Rillentiefe. Genau, und dadurch natürlich auch andere Kapazitäten und sowas.
Das heißt nicht, dass es nicht geht, aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es mit diesen Ertrappen funktioniert, ist halt nicht besonders hoch.
Also ich werd's bei Gelegenheit auch nochmal in Ruhe probieren, nochmal einen anderen Drucker suchen, der wirklich mit hoher Auflösung druckt, der vielleicht noch wo man den Schwarzzelt noch ein bisschen hochdrehen kann, das halt noch ein bisschen mehr Ton rausspuckt. Und ich denke, damit wird's dann auch besser gehen. Aber der Fall war, ich komm dann halt irgendwie, nachdem ich nochmal zurückgefahren bin, das iPhone angeholt hab, komm ich halt irgendwie in den Club an und sitz da und dann klappt's halt einfach nicht mehr. Also es war halt so... Ich war echt so verzweifelt an diesem Abend. Und ich dachte mir, naja, jetzt ist in Amiland gerade so Abend, jetzt werden die ganzen Leute da drüben so richtig loslegen und mit hacken. Und ich hab's halt echt, ich hab's schon abgeschrieben. Und dann wach ich halt am nächsten Tag auf und geh noch schön Mittag essen, weil irgendwie dachte, naja, wenn's jetzt keiner hat, dann dauert's wahrscheinlich eh noch viel länger. Und irgendwie als ich dann vom Mittag wieder kam, war's immer noch nicht, dachte ich, naja, fahr ich halt irgendwie und ätz mal die Leiterplatte. War halt so der, also ne, eigentlich, also ich ging auch davon aus, dass die Leiterplatte nicht funktioniert, weil halt einfach, ähm, die Auflösung nicht reicht. Also dadurch, also das ist ja...
Warte mal, warte mal, ich will das mal kurz, bevor wir weitermachen, ich würde gerne noch mal auf die DPI's zu sprechen bekommen. Das ist ja die, also Dots per Inch ist die Abkürzung. Es gibt die Feinheit eines Drucks an. Ich überleg gerade, kann man vergleichen, wenn ich normalerweise aus dem Laserdrucker was rausbringe, ist das so 150 oder 300 oder sowas.
Äh, 300 oder 600, genau. 300 ist so Standard.
Bildschirm hat 75 so oder 100, wenn sie gut sind. Die Retina Displays haben ein bisschen mehr.
Man soll uns dazu sagen, der Sensor selber hat 500 DPI. Das war so von dem iPhone. Das war eine der wenigen Sachen, die man tatsächlich rausfinden konnte, weil sie damit auch offen geworben haben. Und es ist schon relativ hoch. Also 500 DPI, das ist schon irgendwie so ein... Wie war das vorher? Also eher so 200, 250. Also die optischen waren schon immer besser, die sind halt aber generell viel größer. Und so die ganzen Kapazitiven waren halt eher so im Bereich von 200, 300.
Es gibt ja sozusagen schon in Rechnern und sowas, wo das schon eingebaut ist. Das sind dann alles also die Kapazitiven oder wie?
Ja, genau. Also alles, was in Rechnern drin ist, was in Telefonen ist, ist durch die Bank wäre kapazitiv, weil du halt optisch einfach nicht so klein hinkriegst.
Ja, aber die Technik ist schon anders. Ich glaube, die meisten kennen ja die von diesen Lenovo Laptops. Und das ist schon anders gebaut, als es jetzt beim iPhone ist. Einfach weil man ja bei den Logos oft rüberziehen muss.
Als ich das irgendwie auch das erste Mal gehört hab, dachte ich, dass bei der Apple, also der iTouch, zum Touch ID, zum rauflegen hat und nicht zum rüberziehen, war ich auch erst mal sehr glücklich, weil es halt einfach die Attrappenbau viel einfacher macht. Weil beim rüberziehen musst du halt so auf Stickiness, Kleblichkeit irgendwie aufpassen. Musst im Zweifelsfalle Vitalgumpulver raufmachen, dass du es besser rüberziehen kannst. Und bei rauflegen, das war von vornherein klar, das macht es schon mal deutlich einfacher. Halt, halt. Nicht DPI's?
Doch, gleich. Dauert das noch kurz oder lange?
Naja, die DPI's geht kurz. Also, 500 TPI hat der Scanner selber, also der Fingerabdruckscanner. Das heißt, du solltest, wenn du halt gut sein willst, so mindestens das Doppelte an DPI haben für sowohl den Scan von dem Latentfingerabdruck, also von dem Abdruck, den du halt auf dem Display, also vom Display runter haben willst und für den Ausdruck nachher sollst du irgendwie auch mehr haben. Und, also was ich vorhin sagen wollte, die Leiterplatte beim Ätzen hast du natürlich dann irgendwie unter Ätzung. Das heißt, irgendwie du hast die DPI-Zahl oder die hohe Auflösung wird durch das Ätzen einfach mal wieder minimiert. Und deswegen ging ich eigentlich davon aus, dass Ätzen auch nichts bringt.
Das müssen wir gleich nochmal genauer erzählen. Also gerade Leiterplattenätzen und so ist ja was, was der Hörer wahrscheinlich, genau wie ich, noch überhaupt nie gemacht hat. Ja, Frau Doktor Kurz hat natürlich auch schon mal eine Leiterplatte geätzt. Aber dazu kommen wir später. Wir machen jetzt erstmal das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichtenwetter und Verkehr. Und danach geht es weiter hier im Chaosradio.
So, alle bei denen, der Kopf gerne mal in Nebenluft zieht, jetzt mal hergehört und hürn geschaut.
Gibt's nirgendwo zu kaufen, sondern nur bei Fritz und nur zu gewinnen.
Einfach gut Fritz hören. Ich bin total neuronal veranlagt, habe richtige Dendriten und bin voll gut gegen Pech beim Denken.
Einfach mal angucken auf fritz.de slash Sally.
Mit Mario Bartsch.
Am Heinrich-Heine-Platz in Berlin-Mitte sind zwei Polizisten niedergestochen worden. Ein Polizeisprecher sagte, die Beamten seien wegen häuslicher Gewalt alarmiert worden. Als die beiden Beamten eintrafen, habe ein Mann sie mit einer Schere angegriffen. Die Polizisten wurden schwer verletzt. Jetzt ermittelt die Mordkommission. Berlin bekommt, wie geplant, ein eigenes Stadtwerk. Darauf einigten sich die Spitzen von SPD und CDU in einer Sitzung des Koalitionsausschusses. Demnach soll künftig nur eigenproduzierter Ökostrom angeboten werden. Sollte die Versorgung der Kunden gefährdet sein, kann aber auch Strom zugekauft werden. Das Gesetz soll im Oktober vom Abgeordnetenhaus beschlossen werden. Bisher gehören das Berliner Stromnetz und die Kraftwerke dem schwedischen Energiekonzern Vattenfall. In der CDU-Führung werden Steuererhöhungen als Angebot an einen künftigen Koalitionspartner ausgeschlossen. Generalsekretär Gröhe stellte klar, dass der Spitzensteuersatz nicht verhandelbar sei. Berichte, wonach er eine Erhöhung des Steuersatzes als mögliches Zugeständnis an SPD und Grüne genannt habe, seien falsch. Ähnlich äußerte sich auch Unionsfraktionschef Kauder. Steuererhöhungen seien aus gutem Grund im Regierungsprogramm der CDU und CSU nicht vorgesehen. Daran werde sich auch nichts ändern. Ein erhöhter Spitzensteuersatz für Besserverdienende war ein zentrales Wahlkampfthema von SPD und Grünen. Im Streit um das iranische Atomprogramm kommt nach jahrelangem Stillstand wieder Bewegung. Am Rande der UN-Vollversammlung in New York verhandelt der Iran erstmals mit den fünf ständigen Mitgliedern im UN-Sicherheitsrat und Deutschland. Der iranische Außenminister Zarif versicherte vor Beginn der Gespräche, sein Land wolle konkrete Ergebnisse erzielen und keine Show abziehen. Der Iran steht im Verdacht, unter dem Deckmantel eines zivilen Nuklearprogramms an der Atombombe zu arbeiten. Für Zarif und US-Außenminister Kerry ist es die erste Begegnung. Der Iran und die USA haben seit über 30 Jahren keine diplomatischen Beziehungen mehr. Die aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Köpenick 4, in Wannsee 8 Grad. Wittenberge und Königswusterhausen melden 6, Ludwigsfelde und Prenzlau 7 Grad. Heute Nacht ist es meist locker bewirkt und trocken. Die Temperaturen sinken auf 5 bis 1 Grad. Am Tag ist es dann heiter und sonnig. Nur im Norden kann es auch mal einen Schauer geben. Das Ganze bei maximal 12 bis 15 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin Steglitz. Der Abzweig Steglitz ist zwischen Schildhornstraße und Mecklenburgische Straße gesperrt. Dort gibt es Straßenschäden. Nach Brandenburg B5 nauen Richtung Küritz. Zwischen dem Kreisverkehr Briesen und dem Kreisverkehr Frieser gab es einen Unfall. Dort ist die rechte Spur gesperrt. Wo es geht, gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
So oft ihr wollt und wann ihr wollt. Eine Woche lang im Musikstream.
Heute Chaosradio mit Markus Richter und zu Gast vom Chaos Computer Club im Chaos Radio sind Starbuck und Frau Doktor Konstanze Kurz. Ja bitte, was denn?
Es ist aber gut, ja.
Starbuck hat mir vorher einen großen Kasten Marter versprochen.
Hatte?
Hätte ich die ganze Zeit nur mit Frau Doktor Konstanze.
Bist du so bestechlich?
Nein, ich bin ein öffentlich-rechtlicher Journalist und nicht bestechlich, aber ich tue guten Freunden gerne mal ein Gefallen.
Okay, wenn ich jetzt verspreche, meine GEZ-Gebühren zu erhöhen, wirst du dann aufhören?
Aber das ist ja gar nicht das, über was wir heute reden wollen. Worüber wir heute reden wollen ist ja, und zwar mit Starbuck und Frau Doktor Konstanze kurz, die biometrische, ist das Hacken von Fingerabdrücken bzw. das Nachmachen von Fingerabdrücken. Ihr habt es vielleicht gehört, in den Nachrichten war es ja tatsächlich auch, für das iPhone 5S gibt es einen Fingerabdruckscanner und es gibt jemand, der hat das geschafft, also einen nachgemachten Fingerabdruck zu benutzen, um das iPhone zu entsperren, diese jemanden Starbuck, der hier ist. Und wir haben gerade schon mal erklärt, wie man so einen Fingerabdruck machen kann. Und das ist erschreckend einfach. Man scannt nämlich einfach ein iPhone ab, wo jemand mit seiner Patsche draufgegriffen hat, hat er den Fingerabdruck in einem digitalen Bild, invertiert das, druckt das aus und dann hat man so auf so einer Folie mit einem Laserdrucker, ist das sozusagen ein bisschen erhöht, da kann man dann Holzkaltleim draufgießen und dann ist der Fingerabdruck ausgegossen und damit geht es nicht so gut. Das funktioniert, aber es geht nicht so gut. Es gibt jetzt eine zweite Technologie, um die will Starbuck jetzt gleich erklären, nämlich das Ätzen von Leiterplatten. Wie genau ein Fingerabdruck mit einer geätzten Leiterplatte zu tun hat, finde ich jetzt wirklich sehr interessant. Bitte geh davon aus, dass ich noch nie eine Leiterplatte geätzt habe. Ich weiß nicht mal, was das ist.
Ja, also wie wir gerade festgestellt haben, ist irgendwie die Folie oder die Tonerpartikel auf der ausgedruckten Folie halt irgendwie so 10 Mikrometer dick, also halt nicht wirklich ausreichend dick. Also so die, man kann davon ausgehen, die Rillen im Finger haben halt ungefähr so 100 Mikrometer. Also ein Zehntel Millimeter. Das heißt, was man halt jetzt tut, wenn die Folie nicht funktioniert, braucht man halt Material oder eine Form, die halt tiefe Rillen hat. Dann kann man entweder zum Beispiel einen Lasercutter nehmen und das halt direkt reinschneiden oder man nimmt halt eine Leiterplatte. Also Leiterplatten sind halt so aufgebaut, du hast halt das Leiterplattengrundmaterial und hast dort dann eine Kupferschicht drauf. Die ist halt verschieden dick und guck nicht so, das macht mich ganz wahnsinnig. Ich mach gar nichts. Erzähl weiter. Genau, also diese Kupferschicht ist halt irgendwie 70 Mikrometer in dem Fall dick und das heißt, es kommt schon sehr nah an die 100 Mikrometer, die man haben will für den Finger ran. Dass das Vorgehen jetzt um diese Form aus dieser Leiterplatte rauszubekommen ist, du hast halt den Ausdruck auf der Folie, die man gleich weiterverwenden kann, von der was nicht funktioniert hat. Und das Besondere an diesen Leiterplatten, die ich benutzt habe, das heißt, es sind fotostrukturierbare Leiterplatten. Das heißt, du hast auf der Kupferschicht obendrauf noch mal einen Fotolack. Und das funktioniert so, dass der Fotolack mit UV-Licht belichtet wird. Und je nachdem, was für ein Lack es ist, dort, wo halt das Licht auf den Fotolack auftrifft, vernetzen die Lackpartikel und es wird halt hart.
Und das sind dann die Leiterbahnen oder das sind dann nicht die Leiterbahnen?
Das kommt später. Wir sind jetzt erst beim Belichten. Also der Edge-Schritt, also die Leiterplattenherstellung ist praktisch ein zweigeteilter Schritt. Du hast erst mal diesen Fotolack, der belichtet wird und danach etzt du dann das Kupfer selber. Also du hast einmal Kupferschicht, dann hast du oben den Fotolack drauf und der nächste Schritt, das du praktisch belichtest, den Fotolack. Der wird an manchen Stellen irgendwie hart. Der nicht hart wird, wird halt ausgewaschen im sogenannten Entwicklungsbad. Also genauso wie du auch von früher von Fotos kennst, von Analogfotos, wo du dann halt belichten und entwickeln musstest. Und bei Leiterplatten ist es halt so, du belichtest das, entwickelst das und dann hast du halt genau die Stellen, die belichtet wurden durch das UV-Licht, also die, wo halt auf der Folie, die du ausgedruckt hast, halt keine schwarzen Tonerpartikel sind, hast du dann halt eine Schicht zu stehen. Und das schmeißt du dann einfach in das Edsbad rein. Das heißt dort, wo der Lack oben drauf ist, wo der Lack fest ist, wird halt das Kupfer nicht angegriffen. Dort daneben, also wo halt der Entwickler, die die Fotoschicht weggewaschen hat, da kommt dieses Edsbad direkt ans Kupfer ran und ätzt das Kupfer weg.
Also um der Ehrlichkeit halber, auch diese Leiterplattenätzung ist nicht für diesen Apple-Hack erfunden worden, sondern liegt einfach darin, dass die ganze Prozedur, die wir seit ein paar Jahren machen, die dauerte uns oft zu lange und wir suchten nach einem besseren Material. Starbuck hat da verschiedene Sachen probiert über die Jahre und die Leiterplatte ist jetzt auch schon ein paar Jahre in Benutzung.
Also das war tatsächlich irgendwie so, als die kapazitiven Sensoren irgendwann besser wurden. Und gerade bei Kapazität brauchst du halt wirklich eine gewisse Schichtdicke, weil du halt wirklich dann die Luft als Gegenteil von dem Kleber haben willst. Das heißt, da kannst du nicht nur mit 10 Mikrometer arbeiten, sondern musst du halt schon an den Finger rangehen. Du hast dann die Form, die Form war genau so wie der Fingerabdruck, den ich halt in Wax abgedrückt habe, halt ausreichend tief.
Du hast auf eine Folie den invertierten Fingerabdruck ausgedruckt, das auf die Leiterplatte gelegt und damit belichtet.
Genau. Das heißt, dann weggeätzt.
Dann weggeätzt, so okay.
Also es gibt es gibt positiv und negativ Lack. Das heißt, was du dir gerade im Kopf ausmalst, das ist halt, je nachdem welche Leiterplatte du hast, musst du es entweder invertieren oder nicht. Aber es spielt halt keine Rolle, weil im Endeffekt, also wenn es falsch ist, musst du es halt einfach nochmal andersherum machen. Hab ich auch oft genug, also ich glaube mir, also in dem Fall musst du es sogar nochmal spiegeln, weil du halt die Folie auch noch verkehrtrum auf die Leiterplatte legst.
Aber spielt alles keine Rolle.
Also wie gesagt, ich habe da schon öfter diesen Fehler gemacht, deswegen.
Und dann hast du dann sozusagen diesen Fingerabdruck auf einer Leiterplatte.
Genau, das ist negativ. Dann kann man eigentlich jetzt loslegen und den Holzleim, so wie man es auf die Folie gemacht hat, halt den Holzleim auf die Leiterplatte raufgießen. Man muss dazu sagen, dass das halt, also gerade mit dem Holzleim und Leiterplatte ist halt alles nicht so gut, weil es klebt, das ist halt Leim, das heißt, der klebt irgendwie auf dem Leiterplattenmaterial relativ gut. Das heißt eigentlich will man da noch so eine Trennerschicht drauf haben. Dann nimmst man entweder Teflonspray, ist halt irgendwie teuer, hat nicht jeder. Oder was ich halt irgendwie mal rausgefunden hab, ist Grafittspray, eignet sich halt total super. Also halt einfach, um den getrockneten Leim nachher besser abziehen zu können. Der Vorteil an Grafittspray ist außerdem noch, dass Grafitt irgendwie auch nochmal eine eigene hohe Kapazität, also eine Kapazitätskonstante hat. Das heißt irgendwie, damit kann man nochmal viel besser Finger emulieren, also eine höhere Kapazität dann damit erzeugen.
Also die Attrappe wirkt mehr wie ein menschlicher Finger für so ein Sensor.
Genau, weil das Grafitt sozusagen dem, was die menschliche Haut hat, ähnlich ist.
Genau, also das ist ja immer so der Trick bei Attrappematerial aussuchen, dass du halt dem Finger möglichst ähnlich sein willst und dieses Grafitt macht das halt einfach nochmal besser und zusätzlich kann man irgendwie den Abdruck selber, die Attrappe selber besser abziehen. Und das ist eigentlich schon tatsächlich jetzt der ganze Trick dabei. Also dann die Attrappe abgezogen, hab meinen Finger genommen, hab den Finger eingelernt, hab's halt erstmal probiert mit meinem eigenen Finger, ging natürlich freischalten, hab dann die Attrappe genommen, hab's irgendwie halt aufgelegt und hat auf Anhieb funktioniert und halt so wirklich regelmäßig beim ersten Mal, also maximal irgendwie so jedes zweite Mal. Und das war dann halt so Sonntagabend, so gegen vier, fünf und dann war irgendwie so cool. Hat einfach funktioniert, hat geklappt und...
Ja, wir hatten halt derweil dann schon ja auch irgendwie die Meldungen natürlich vorbereitet, weil wirkte schon so, als wenn es jetzt bald soweit ist. Und irgendwie hat auch niemand daran gezweifelt, dass wir, nun war ja grad der Tag der Bundestagswahl, dass wir trotzdem unmittelbar, egal zu welchem Zeitpunkt, wirklich fertig sein würden, raushauen müssen. Im Prinzip, als das Video hochgeladen war. Aber wir sind natürlich dann doch ein bisschen beschimpft worden dafür, weil als wir draus geschickt hatten, die Uhrzeit so 20 Uhr war. Also genau in die Ergebnisse der Bundestagswahl hinein. Und zumindest die deutsche Presse, die internationale natürlich nicht. Aber die deutsche hat da so teilweise so ein bisschen piefig drauf reagiert. Und wie wir denn, ob wir das nicht vielleicht doch zu einem günstigeren Zeitpunkt hätten veröffentlichen wollen. Und wir hatten es natürlich übersetzt. Weil uns von vornherein klar war, das sollte keine deutsche Meldung sein. Sondern das wird sicherlich aufgrund, als einfach der Tatsache, dass Apple international gelauncht hat, diese neue Telefon. Das wird ja einfach international verticken wollen.
Ich würde über die Pressesache gleich noch sprechen wollen. Ich hätte noch ein, zwei technische Fragen zum Fingerabdruck machen. Und zwar zum, also A, die Frage nochmal, dieses Holz-Kalt-Lime-Finger-Abbild, muss man das dann auf einem menschlichen Finger tragen? Oder ist es egal, ob man das auf einem Holzstück macht oder auf einem, keine Ahnung?
Das ist tatsächlich egal. Also ich hatte irgendwie auch Attrappen gehabt, die halt, wenn sie ausreichend dick sind, die tatsächlich auf dem Phone drauf lagen und einfach so funktioniert haben, ohne dass irgendjemand irgendwas drücken musste. Die waren halt einfach oben drauf und hat dann wieder das mal freigeschaltet, wenn man nur das Telefon angeschaltet hat. Das heißt, das schließt halt schon mal diese ganzen Aussagen mit, wir brauchen lebende Finger und irgendwie abgehackte Finger, wer nicht erkannt, irgendwie schon mal per se aus.
Es gibt so ein bisschen Gründe, warum dieser Holz-Lime so über die Jahre oft benutzt wurde. Weil früher, wenn wir Attrappen gebaut haben, sollte die ja auch möglich so sein, dass man die nicht so sieht. Das heißt, wenn wir die auf unsere eigenen Finger aufgebracht haben, um etwa, also bei der CeBIT hat man mal so ein Jahr, wo wir in Gruppen ausgeströmt sind, um verschiedene biometrische Sensoren zu testen, dann sollten die halt möglich durchsichtig sein, dass man die aufnehmen kann und nicht gleich irgendwie der Messeronkel, der da rumsteht, da sieht, was man vor hat. Mittlerweile gibt es aber auch andere Materialien. Also Holz-Lime ist nicht mehr alternativlos.
Also der erste öffentliche Hack, den ich tatsächlich gemacht hab, war damals in Offenburg, so ein kleines Nest in Baden-Württemberg, wo sich so ein Elektronikladen mal so ein System geholt hat und man konnte dort tatsächlich Computer mit Fingerabdruck kaufen. Also das war ein Laden, wo man Elektronik im Wert von 10.000 Euro hätte kaufen können und mit dem Fingerabdruck bezahlen. Und da war es natürlich besonders wichtig, dass der nicht sieht, dass du eine Trappe drauf hast. Und dann bin ich wirklich hingegangen mit dem dünnen Holz-Lime, was man nicht gesehen hat und hab mir dann irgendwie ein Mauspad oder sowas gekauft. Einfach aus Spaß. Ich hab letztens bei mir aufgeräumt und noch so die Unterlagen von damals gefunden. Die Rechnung und meine Einwilligung, dass sie das Geld von meinem Konto abbuchen dürfen und so weiter.
Also später kam diese Prozedur bei den Ethikermärkten. Im Süden haben die ja diese Fingerabdruckbezahlsysteme noch mal durchgeführt, aber da waren wir nicht mal bei. Also da haben wir sozusagen nur den Journalisten, das war ARD, nehme ich recht erinnere, nur erklärt, wie man das machen muss und die haben es auch geschafft. Es gab ja schon so eine gewisse Routine, aber diese Holzlein war am praktischsten, wenn man das ordentlich anklebt, da sah man das wirklich kaum. Es sah halt nur aus wie so ein bisschen glänzenderer Finger.
Also man muss halt irgendwie sagen, tatsächlich wenn das Angriffsszenario ist, du klaust ein Telefon oder du findest ein Telefon mit Fingerabdruck drauf, dann ist ja egal, ob du irgendwie das versteckst oder nicht. Das heißt, es würde einfach alles gehen, also irgendwie ohne Finger dahinter.
Okay, jetzt muss man ja, dazu auch noch eine Frage, wenn ich jetzt so ein Telefon finde, da sind ja Fingerabdrücke drauf. Wie hoch ist denn die Wahrscheinlichkeit, habt ihr das mal ausprobiert, dass ich dann auch den richtigen erwische? Oder kann man erkennen, welcher der Daumen ist und welcher der andere?
Nein, du musst halt nicht den Daumen einlernen, du kannst den einlernen, wenn du willst.
Ich glaube, die meisten Leute lernen ihren Daumen ein und du erkennst den Daumen relativ gut, weil er halt schon deutlich breiter ist als die anderen Finger.
Was ist denn das Problem mit diesen ganzen Linkshändlern, die dann eventuell rechts einlernen, aber links benutzen, ist natürlich ein Problem.
Also man muss ja dazusagen, Du musst doch den Finger einlernen, den auch benutzt oder nicht?
Achso, du meinst sozusagen, die rechts entsperren, aber links immer sozusagen.
Aber unabhängig davon, du musst ja natürlich den Fingerabdruck nicht vom Display nehmen, sondern du kannst den Fingerabdruck ja auch vom Sensor selber nehmen. Habe ich nicht ausprobiert, aber es ist auch ein durchaus reflektierendes Material, ein glossy Material. Also man sieht ihn nicht ganz so gut wie auf dem Display und die Fläche ist natürlich viel kleiner, aber prinzipiell spricht nichts dagegen, irgendwie den letzten praktisch funktionierenden Abdruck, weil der letzte, der drauf ist, ist wahrscheinlich der, der es freigeschaltet hat, den zu benutzen, um damit die ganze Prozedur durchzuführen.
Aber trotzdem noch zu dem Fingerabdruck, ich habe irgendwie im Hinterkopf, das ist zumindest in der früheren Anwendung, mal irgendwas mit Dämpfen von Sekundenkleber und Fingerabdruck von Gläsern abnehmen, also sagen, man hat ja nicht immer eine glatte spiegelnde Oberfläche zur Verfügung, wo zufällig auch noch der richtige Fingerabdruck drauf ist.
Das war das, was ich vorhin meinte, irgendwie mit dem Scanner direkt, also das Telefon auf den Scanner gelegt und ich war halt selber sehr überrascht, dass es einfach so gute Bilder macht und ich habe auch wirklich nicht mal irgendwie jetzt schöne Fingerabdrücke gemacht, sondern wirklich normale Benutzung, aber das hat tatsächlich glaube ich auch viel geholfen. Also Freunde von mir, die den Hack praktisch nachgebildet haben, die hatten halt irgendwie alte Leiterplatten gehabt, die sie halt wirklich mit Zyanakrylat, also Sekundenkleberdämpfen damals belichtet haben und da hat es nicht funktioniert. Also die Attrappen gingen nicht und die Vermutung ist, dass tatsächlich die Dämpfe sich ja irgendwie anlagern und das Ganze halt breiter machen, das heißt die Form leicht verändern und das schon ausreicht, im Zusammenhang mit der hohen Auflösung des Sensors selber den Fingerabdruck so anders aussehen zu lassen, dass es dann nicht mehr funktioniert.
Das muss man vielleicht noch ein bisschen genauer erklären. Was wir früher gemacht haben war ja vor allen Dingen, dass wir Abdrücke, die zum Beispiel auf einem Glas waren oder so, dass man die mit diesen Dämpfen, die sich da anlagern, sichtbarer macht. Damit werden aber, also wenn man sich jetzt mal so ein Finger anguckt, wo man ja die Minutes auch sehen kann, damit werden sozusagen die Größen der Rillen verändert, einfach wegen der Anlagerung. Aber nun hat sich in diesen acht Jahren natürlich auch die Technik verändert. Wir haben heute normale Scanner, die deutlich besser auflösen, scannen. Wir haben Fotoapparate, mit denen man heute Aufnahmen machen kann, was früher nicht möglich war. Das heißt, es ist auch so ein bisschen obsolet geworden.
Also die Kollegen, von denen ich gerade erzählt habe, die haben den Hack nachgebaut und haben es dann auch geschafft, also irgendwie zwei Tage später. Und was die gemacht haben, ist nicht, die hatten halt keinen guten Scanner. Sie haben tatsächlich ein anderes iPhone genommen und mit der iPhone-Kamera den Fingerabdruck auf dem anderen iPhone abfotografiert und dann war es hier kaputt geworden, was eigentlich noch mal viel cooler ist.
Die Auflösung ist ja heute auch ziemlich gut von den Kameras.
Ich habe vor allen Dingen, ich habe irgendwo so ein Bild gesehen, wo jemand einen ganz kleinen Hack gemacht hat. Und da hat er die Linse aus einem Laserpointer genommen, vor die iPhone-Kamera einfach geklebt, mit einer Büroklammer oder sowas. Und dann hast du halt so ein richtiges Mikrofon, eine ganz richtig große, äh... Und dann noch die Frage, man fotografiert diesen Fingerabdruck, wie schwierig ist es eigentlich, das richtige Größenverhältnis zu haben? Der Fingerabdruck muss ja genauso groß ausgedruckt werden, wie er dann letztendlich war. Wie macht man das? Legt man da ein Maßband daneben?
Wenn man scannt, ist es natürlich... Das ist automatisch die richtige Größe. Bei dem Fotografieren, was ich auch einen sehr coolen Trick fand, die haben einfach einen Rahmen rumgelegt. Die haben sich einen 2 cm großen Rahmen geschnitten, den mitfotografiert und dann so weit ausgedruckt oder so lang skaliert, dass der Rahmen 2 cm groß ist. Damit hast du automatisch den Fingerabdruck auch in der richtigen Größe. Auch ein sehr cooler Hack. Wenn du mit Kamera machst, musst du skalieren. Das ist eine wirklich einfache Möglichkeit, das zu tun. Das hat auch funktioniert. Vielleicht noch kurz, weil ich gerade von den Ex-Kollegen geredet hab. Ich hab natürlich auch noch auf anderen Wege versucht, an ein iPhone zu kommen. Einer von den Kollegen war zufälligerweise gerade in Amerika und ich hab ihm gesagt, du bring mir meins mit. Weil ich weiß nicht, ob ich hier eins kriege und ich will das mit mir hacken. Der kam halt Sonntagabend zurück. Gegen acht rief er mich dann an. Ich hab ihm auch gesagt, wir hacken das zusammen, wenn du da bist. Er rief mich glücklich an, ich bin da, ich hab das neue iPhone mitgebracht. Und ich so, äh, du, tut mir leid, wir haben es schon kaputt gemacht.
Das ist natürlich sehr schade.
Nur um das mal abzuschließen festzuhalten, dieser Hack ist jetzt sozusagen beendet. Also das ist nicht irgendwie so ein Prototyp, sondern genau so kann man das auch immer wieder machen.
Genau so kann man das machen und genau so kann es wirklich jeder machen. Also auch dieses Ätzen, was halt, wenn wir gleich auf die Presse zu sprechen kommen, haben so viele meckfreundliche Blogs und Presseorgane gestiegen. Das ist ja kein realistisches Szenario, weil wer ätzt denn schon? Aber du kannst tatsächlich zu Hause in der Küche ätzen. Und ich bin mir auch, wie gesagt, ich hab's ja schon gesagt, mit Folie geht's auch. Und ich werd mir die nächsten Tage oder Wochen irgendwie noch mal das ein bisschen genauer zu Gemüte führen, das mit der Folie noch mal optimieren. Ich bin mir sicher, dass es mit der Folie auch in ordentlich reproduzierbar geht. Und dann fällt dieser Ätzschritt weg und dann ist es halt wirklich Kinderkacke.
Das kann man nicht immer sagen. Da muss man wirklich mal zu sagen, Folie bedeutet, ein Bild in einen Leserdrucker reintun und das einfach auf Folie auszupacken. Und dann hat man sozusagen ein fertiges Ding. Ich will trotzdem noch mal nach deiner Einschätzung fragen. Ich meine, du machst das seit Jahren. Du hast ja gerade gesagt, wenn du dich ordentlich vorbereitet hättest, wär das Ding nach einer halben Stunde kaputt gewesen. Jemand, der noch keine Erfahrung damit hat, nennen wir ihn ein eifersüchtigen Ihemann X, der unbedingt mal lesen möchte, was seine Frau so im iPhone hat. Der macht das alles zum ersten Mal. Wie lange braucht der, wenn er nicht ganz doof ist?
Wird er schon einen Tag brauchen?
Also ein paar Stunden. Wir haben eine Anleitung veröffentlicht, wirklich eine Schritt für Schritt-Anleitung, da sieht man genau, was man machen muss. Die Schritte selber sind weder kompliziert, das heißt, das kann jeder machen, und sie brauchen auch nicht lange. Die längste Zeit, die man braucht, ist zu warten, bis der Holzleim ausgetrunken ist.
Und noch im Baumarkt gehen, wenn du keinen Holzleim zu Hause hast.
So ein Tag ist auf jeden Fall vollkommen ausreichend, um das zu machen.
Also bei den Workshops, die wir so gemacht haben, die es übrigens auch an Schulen gab, da können auch Kinder schon, da haben wir eigentlich nie jemand dabei gehabt, der das nicht konnte.
Das haben wirklich alle hingekriegt, und wir waren in der Regel nach drei Stunden.
Nee, mit drei Stunden haben wir aber schon die Zappa gebaut. Wir haben meistens Workshops zusammen, wo wir Treppen bauen und auch Zappa, um diese RFID-Ships, wo die Biometrie aufgespeichert ist, zu deaktivieren.
Du meinst, damit kann man die Fingerbrücke im Reisepass kaputt machen?
Naja, den Inhalt des Chips sozusagen unläsbar machen.
Also das ist immer der Doppelschlag.
Das waren dann schon drei Stunden.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist eigentlich kein großer Akt. Und du bist halt in wenigen Stunden durch damit.
Ich hab tatsächlich hier auch einen Kollegen gemacht, und dann hab ich es auch erzählt, dass wir das heute machen. Ihr habt ja möglicherweise nicht nur den Hack gemacht, sondern euch auch überlegt, wer Interesse daran haben könnte, ein iPhone aufzumachen. Also zwei Dinge liegen auf der Hand. Das eine ist, ich finde das iPhone und will halt mal gucken, was da so drin ist. Und das andere ist halt, das ist aus meinem näheren Umfeld und ich möchte mal gucken, ob da nicht noch ein anderer Typ mit meiner Freundin schreibt. Was gibt's noch für Denkware?
Also der Hack ist einfach gar nicht iPhone bezogen. Der Hack ist halt Fingerabdrucksensor technisch oder Fingerabdrucksystem bezogen. Und es war jetzt einfach eine gute Gelegenheit, das nochmal wieder auszuprobieren. Ich hab immer, wenn mal wieder neue Sensoren rauskamen, so das Thinkpad, weil es rauskam mit Fingerabdruck, einfach mal eins geholt, da mal probiert und jetzt mal probiert. Und das ist halt einfach die Szenarien jetzt irgendwie so auf Apple und iPhones runterzubrechen, finde ich irgendwie zielführend.
Was gibt's denn noch?
Wir haben natürlich in der Zeit, das ist ja auch öffentlich öfter mal gemacht worden, dass wir das machen, auch oft Angebote bekommen. Also immer von den Herstellern, die dann sagen, also wir haben hier, wollt ihr mal testen? In letzter Zeit hatten wir interessanterweise ziemlich viele Leute, die uns geschrieben haben, wegen Waffen, die mit Biometrie, also vor allen Dingen Fingerabdrucksensoren bestückt sind. Aber wir machen natürlich keine Form von irgendwie so Aufträgen, sondern ist einfach etwa klar, alle haben darüber gesprochen. Also hat nichts mit Apple zu tun, sondern ist einfach das erste große Konsumerprodukt.
Ich will jetzt gerade noch mal ein bisschen darüber sprechen. Biometrische Waffen habe ich bis jetzt für Science-Fiction gehalten?
Oh ja, schon lange, schon mehrere Jahre.
Freigeschaltet, also kannst du halt nur abdrücken, wenn du vorher deinen Fingerabdruck drauf gelegt hast. Was ja durchaus Sinn macht.
Kindersicherung halt zum Beispiel.
Ob es mit ihrer Waffe wurde jemand erschossen, oder sie können ja durch ihren Fingerabdruck freigeschaltet werden.
Nein, es soll eine Sicherung dagegen sein. Das dritte zum Beispiel. Polizisten haben sowas. Also nicht in Deutschland, aber anderswo. Wenn dir jemand die Waffe klaut, er sie nicht gegen dich benutzt.
Ich dachte, das ist doch gerade ein mögliches Angriffsszenario. Ich klaue die Waffe immer an jemand mit so einem Fingerabdruck.
Ja, aber die Attrappe bauen dauert schon einen Moment. Du kannst ihn nicht sofort erschießen.
Aber jemand anders und ihm dann den Mord in die Schuhe schieben.
Ach so, das ist natürlich auch nochmal was ganz anderes. Ja, ja, ja. Ich weiß, da ein gutes Szenario, was wir tatsächlich in den letzten Tagen durchgespielt haben in der Theorie. Du kannst natürlich den Fingerabdruck nachmachen. Du nimmst dir kurz dein Telefon, entsperrst es, schiebst ihn in Kinderpornografie rauf. Und wenn er irgendwie am nächsten Flughafen irgendwie sein Telefon anschaltet und da ist irgendwie im Hintergrundbild ein Kiddie-Porn, dann ist natürlich für ihn deutlich schwierig zu erklären, dass es nicht von ihm kommt. Also du kannst halt sehr gut Leute damit in Situationen bringen, wo sie nicht hinwollen. Also im schlimmsten Fall natürlich ein Mordanhängen. Aber halt irgendwie alles, was damit irgendwie freigeschaltet wird. Und du halt nicht beweisen kannst, dass du es nicht warst, weil man geht einfach davon aus, Fingerabdruck gehört dir, deswegen warst du es auch, der ihn benutzt hast. Kann man sich halt diverse Szenarien durchspielen.
Es geht ja einfach darum, dass man Risiken erkennt, auch wenn die jetzt natürlich, vielleicht nicht irgendwie so ein Everyday-Szenario sind.
Natürlich nicht, weil oft halt auch das Gegenargument kommt, das braucht doch niemand. Und es brauchen vielleicht nicht alle, aber manche vielleicht schon. Wir reden jetzt gleich mal über den Presse-Fallout. Also was passiert ist, nachdem dieser Hack wirklich an den Tag getreten ist. Und die spannende Frage, warum das jetzt erst, wann war euer erstes Video von Fingerabdruck machen?
2004. Achso, ja 2004.
2004, 20 Uhr. Und erst jetzt ist das so ein riesen Ding geworden. Jetzt, wo ein Lifestyleprodukt gar nicht wurde. Darüber reden wir gleich. Macht jetzt eine kurze Pause und danach sind wir wieder für euch da. Und da gibt es heute, das erkennt ihr schon am altbekannten Geräusch, das Chaos Radio in Blue Moon. Das heißt die Sendung, wo einmal im Monat der Chaos Computer Club hier die ganzen Studios übernimmt und wir nicht genau wissen, was er macht.
Meistens macht er etwas kaputt.
Heute ist das eine Fingerabdruckscanner, der kaputt gemacht wurde. Mal wieder muss man auch dazu sagen. Zu Gast sind Starbuck und Frau Dr. Konstanze Kurz. Guten Abend.
Ey Markus, jetzt ist er aber wirklich nicht mehr lustig.
Das entscheide immer noch ich. Wir reden über einen Fingerabdruckscanner. Wir haben die erste Stunde dazu genutzt, um zu erklären, wie das technisch geht. Also wie man das macht, dass man einen Fingerabdruckscanner so überlistet, dass er einen gefälschten Fingerabdruck, also einen nachgemachten, akzeptiert. Und das kann man auch nachmachen. Ich würde gerne noch mal kurz zusammenfassen, wie das geht. Aber das würde wahrscheinlich wirklich zu kompliziert sein. Das heißt, ihr müsstet euch, wenn ihr jetzt erst einsteigt, das als Podcast anhören. Den gibt es ja dann auf fritz.de und chaosradio.de.
Oder Video klicken.
Oder das Video klicken und wir kommen jetzt gleich sozusagen zu der gesellschaftlichen Konsequenz daraus und der Pressearbeit, die daraus entstanden ist und gemacht werden musste. Vorher aber noch mal das Angebot an euch. Falls ihr Fragen habt zu dem Thema, könnt ihr gerne anrufen. 0331 70 97 110. Und das hat nämlich auch der Robin gemacht. Robin21 aus Frankfurt. Hallo Robin. Du hattest noch ein paar Fragen.
Ja, ich hab noch zwei Fragen dazu. Zum einen, was das iPhone angeht, würde mich mal interessieren, wiefern ihr das so auseinander genommen habt und mal geschaut habt, okay, ist das eigentlich bei dem Fingerabdruck so, wie es auch gesagt wird, dass da quasi halt so eine Prüfsumme eben auf dem Chip gespeichert wird, der Fingerabdruck eigentlich gar nicht weiter verarbeitet werden kann oder inwiefern vielleicht doch die Möglichkeit besteht, mal eben schnell übers Internet, mal zu Apple zum Beispiel, wo es dann schön irgendwo gespeichert wird. Inwiefern dieser Fingerabdruck also wirklich mehr auf dem Chip verarbeitet wird oder vielleicht doch irgendwie weiter geschickt werden könnte, ob da schon irgendwie was feststeht mittlerweile?
Haben wir noch nicht gemacht und ich gehe davon aus, also wenn das jemand tut, dann dauert das noch ein bisschen, weil das ist tatsächlich deutlich schwieriger zu machen als halt den Fingerabdruck nachzubauen. Ich vermute mal ganz stark, also irgendwas knackt hier. Also normalerweise, also halt frühere Sensoren speichern halt normalerweise Minute-Positionen. Das heißt, wenn du einen Fingerabdruck hast, dann hast du halt diese Hautrillen und die verzweigen sich irgendwann. Das nennt man Minute und die werden normalerweise benutzt. Und wenn man auch nur die abspeichert, kann man halt den Fingerabdruck nicht rekonstruieren. Was ich aus den Winning Informationen rausgelesen hab, die Apple dazu gegeben hat, speichern sie anscheinend tatsächlich den gesamten Verlauf der Fingerlinien auch mit. Das heißt, ich gehe davon aus oder ich vermute, dass wenn man tatsächlich irgendwie an die abgespeicherten Template hat, also sie werden halt kein Bild abspeichern, damit bin ich relativ sicher, ist auch viel zu groß und so. Aber wenn sie tatsächlich diese Fingerrillen, Daten abspeichern, denke ich schon, dass man daraus den Fingerabdruck wieder rekonstruieren kann. Aber es ist halt nur meine Vermutung.
Vielleicht sollte man dazu noch sagen, dass ich glaube, dieser Touch-ID-Hack hat schon auch so eine Welle ausgelöst, international von Leuten, die jetzt auch Bock haben, um zu untersuchen, wir sind ja nicht die Einzigen, die sich dafür interessieren. Mir scheint, dass da auch so eine Art Wettbewerb entstanden ist. Und da wird es sicherlich nicht nur um den Sensor an sich gehen, sondern auch um die Daten, wo sie hingespeichert sind, wie sie gespeichert sind, ob sie übertragen werden können. Ich glaube, das ist eine Frage der Zeit.
Also ich weiß auf jeden Fall, dass Leute dran sind. Aber ich weiß auch, dass es halt schon deutlich komplizierter Prozess ist und das wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen dauert. Auf jeden Fall irgendwie, man guckt sich das an.
Das ist ja auch sozusagen, also nur um es mal kurz zu erklären, das ist ja auch eine sehr interessante Frage, weil wenn in dem Gerät der Fingerabdruck gespeichert ist, dann kann man ja nicht nur, wenn man das Gerät hat sozusagen, also in der Hand das Gerät hat, möglicherweise den Abdruck auslesen und danach machen, sondern man könnte ja möglicherweise auch so ein iPhone mal hacken und den Fingerabdruck irgendwo hin verschicken lassen, dann so eine kleine Datenbank von gehackten iPhone-Finger und so weiter und so fort. Das gucken wir uns nochmal an. Hast du noch eine Frage Robin?
Ja, ich hab noch eine Frage und zwar, wie sieht das aus mit dem Fingerabdrucknachbau bei Sachen, wo es wirklich drauf ankommt? Also sagen wir mal, zum Beispiel bei deinem neuen Personalausweis oder beim Reisepass, ist das da genauso einfach nachzumachen oder ist das nochmal schon irgendwie ein bisschen was anderes?
Das ist tatsächlich noch einfacher. Also das ist das, was Sie vorhin schon erklärt haben. Da geht es halt wirklich mit dem Ausdruck von der Folie abziehen. Also da musst du nicht ätzen und nix. Aber die Sensoren sind halt optisch.
Der Scanner ist einfach, die Qualität ist viel geringer.
Die Auffallung ist tatsächlich ähnlich, aber sie ist schon optischer. Da reicht halt wirklich diese dünne Schicht, die von der Folie abgezogen wird. Also haben wir auch schon vor, vor Jahren, als Sie den damals auf der CeBIT vorgestellt haben, den Scanner haben wir das irgendwie einmal gemacht. Und es ist genauso.
Könnten wir aber bei der Gelegenheit darauf hinweisen, dass es optional ist und vollkommen freiwillig, seinen Fingerabdruck beim Ausweis abzugeben. Und wir raten davon ab.
Natürlich, der wird ja genauso auch nicht gespeichert.
Nee, natürlich nicht. Und auch nicht von der NSA ausgelesen.
Nein, ganz, ganz bestimmt nicht. Jetzt hätte ich aber noch zu dem NPA auch noch ein persönliches kurzes Problem. Dürfte ich das noch kurz fragen?
Ja, aber dann sollten wir sagen, dass der NPA nämlich genau dieser elektronische Personalausweis ist. E-P-A. Wir nennen ihn E-P-A, weil wir diese Umbenennung nicht mitgemacht haben.
Ich bin vielleicht zu brainwashed irgendwie. Das kann natürlich sein.
Na, sag mal.
Weil mein Problem ist, ich hab die letzten fünf Jahre im Ausland gelebt, hab aber diese Thematik sehr intensiv mitverfolgt, bin jetzt dann Anfang des Jahres wieder zurück nach Deutschland, hab mir den dann halt auch geholt. Und wusste nicht genau, wie verbreitet der schon ist und hab gedacht, weil bei mir ist es so, ich bin vollständig blind und hab eben gedacht, okay, vielleicht eine ganz coole Sache mit dieser elektronischen Signatur und so, bla, bla. Hab mir das besorgt und hab aber festgestellt, dass dieses Programm, mit dem man auf den Personatausweis zugreift, über so einen Kartenleser mit einem Screenreader, also das ist quasi dieses Programm, was für einen blinden Menschen eben den Text in eine Sprache umwandelt, dass das überhaupt gar nicht bedienbar ist.
Hast du die BSI-App dafür, also hast du die drunter geladen von einer...
Ja, diese Ausweis-App, ja genau.
Genau, okay. Ja, und es gibt auch mittlerweile einige Firmen, die das anbieten. Da müsstest du vielleicht mal probieren, ob du noch eine bessere findest, wenn die... Also die hilft dir eigentlich überhaupt nicht, ne?
Ja, weil das funktioniert dir überhaupt gar nicht. Weil das Problem ist, das ist ja alles, das ist ja diese ganze Java-Code und so. Und das ist prinzipiell eigentlich nicht wirklich nutzbar. Also allgemein, diese ganze Java-Geschichte. Und eigentlich gibt es auch eine Verordnung dafür, die eben vorschreibt, dass eben so staatliche, behördliche Anwendungen auch zugänglich sein müssen.
Okay, Robin, wir verlassen gerade, glaube ich, den Bereich des Fingerkurs.
Das tut mir auch leid. Ich wollte noch mal fragen, ob es da vielleicht irgendwie eine Möglichkeit gäbe, irgendwas dagegen zu machen.
Zumindest eins würde ich auf jeden Fall machen. Ich glaube, das ist ein brechiges Interesse. Und ich denke, da würde ich mich bei der Behörde, das ist ja jede BSI, auch mal zu Wort melden. Da würden wir dich im Zweifel auch unterstützen.
Das fände ich super, weil ich habe ehrlich gesagt auch schon, das ist wirklich der letzte Weg, denn ich gehe über das Radio.
Magst du mal noch eine Mail an biometrie.ccc.de schicken? Dann kriegen wir das auch.
Finde ich auch wichtig. Wir haben eh sehr viele Versprechungen bei diesem Ausweis, nicht eingelöst, das wäre eine mehr. Und da bist du ja sicherlich auch nicht alleine.
So ist es nämlich, genau.
Mach das mal.
Biometrie, ccc.de, viel Spaß beim Schreiben.
Jetzt werde ich erstmal noch viel Spaß haben am Zuhören. Vielen Dank.
So, sehr gut. Und jetzt kommen wir, also wie gesagt, wenn ihr noch Fragen habt, ähnlich wie Robin, könnt ihr gerne noch anrufen, 0331 70 97 110. Und wir wollen jetzt aber mal die andere Seite betrachten. Ausgangspunkt für die andere Seite ist sozusagen die öffentliche Wahrnehmung des Problems Biometrie und Fingerabdrücke. Wir haben schon gehört, 2004 hat der Chaos Computer Club zum ersten Mal gezeigt, wie einfach es ist, einen Fingerabdruckscanner zu überlisten. Und es ist dieses Jahr, 2013, hat es das am Wahlabend auf die Titelseiten einiger Online-Zeitungen gebracht. Und da fragt man sich natürlich sozusagen, okay, das sind jetzt neun Jahre. Es hat neun Jahre gedauert. Und es hat anscheinend ein Lifestyleprodukt gebraucht.
Das ist nicht ganz richtig.
Starbucks und Konz, bitte, lasst mich doch noch kurz die Einladung machen, weil das ist die öffentliche Wahrnehmung. Die öffentliche Wahrnehmung ist genau das. Ich muss hier gleich mal jemanden pelpen. Frau Doktor Kurz, vielen Dank, dass Sie das gesagt haben.
Du hast doch den Regel an der Hand.
Also der Punkt ist sozusagen, dass in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung ist tatsächlich die Biometrie jetzt erst eine große Tatsache. Und das ist sozusagen mit dem iPhone, weil es ein so wichtiges Lifestyleprodukt ist. Aber, und das haben die beiden mir schon vorher erzählt, der Anfang, dass das Presseinteresse so groß war, begann schon zu sagen, bevor der Hack überhaupt bekannt war, nämlich mit, ist Touch ID hacked yet?
Darauf wollte ich gar nicht hin. Du möchtest dich ausreden. Was ich nämlich sagen wollte, also es war tatsächlich gerade in Deutschland schon mal relativ groß in der Presse und zwar damals zu Schäuble-Zeiten. Also als wir den Schäuble-Fingerabdruck. Und das war durchaus, also jetzt ist es international natürlich viel, viel größer. Aber für Deutschland, würde ich sagen, war es auf jeden Fall zu der Zeit. Das war vor drei Jahren oder so was.
Na, es war schon mal ein Nachrichtenthema, aber sozusagen aber so ein Thema, wo man, also weißt du, so Atomwaffen sind halt auch ein Nachrichtenthema. Das interessiert jeden. Aber jetzt die persönliche Betroffenheit ist nicht so da. Und jetzt ist es halt einfach so, dass das jetzt so klar wird und ich habe auch das Gefühl, dass mehr in diese Richtung berichtet wird, dass das ein Problem ist, das tatsächlich jeden Einzelnen jetzt betrifft. Das ist halt das andere. Klar, als wir damals den Schäuble-Fingerabdruck in der Datenschleuder ausgeliefert haben, da war das sozusagen ein News-Thema.
Nee, ich würd's eigentlich dennoch nicht unterschreiben. Weil ich glaube, dass damals die Debatte, wir müssen uns ja mal erinnern, 2005 im November kamen die ersten Reisepässe, die die Biometrie drin hatten. Und 2007 in der nächsten Stufe und dann 2011 der Ausweis. Es war schon so, dass die Biometrie jeden betroffen hat. Und der Schäuble-Abdruck, wo wir ja auch nur erklärt haben, dass das als Sicherheitstechnik eigentlich nicht gut geeignet ist und warum, der landete auf der, ich darf das mal, wenn ich mich daran erinnere... Ja, Bild. Also in deutschen Verhältnissen war das schon, und da gab es auch eine Menge Hype und Fernsehsendungen, aber wir haben jetzt halt eine internationale Dimension. Und das betrifft aber im Grunde weniger Leute. Weil also ein Ausweis oder Pass hat jeder, das ist ja quasi dann zwangsweise, aber ein iPhone hat nun nicht jeder. Insofern ist das schon eine ausgesuchte Gruppe von Gadget-Lovern, die auch gerade sich so für die Einführung interessieren.
Deutlich weniger problematische Anwendung auch. Also war halt nicht der Staat tatsächlich die Daten, sondern halt...
Das ist einfach eine andere Gruppe, die man jetzt anspricht, aber nicht unbedingt eine kleinere. Wir haben also so ein bisschen, ich glaube, dass es so dicke kommt, haben wir auch nicht vermutet. Aber so ganz überrascht hat es uns natürlich auch nicht. Also war natürlich Apple gerade so als Technologievorreiter, wie sie sich ja nach wie vor auch inszenieren, ein hoher Interesse hat, gerade so bei den Technikseiten, die darüber berichten. Und dann gab es eben, was du eben ansprachst.
Also Apple ist auf jeden Fall nicht schuld, dass es so gut in der Presse war, weil Apple, wie so oft bei Problemen mit Apple-Produkten schweigt, ist einfach tot. Also ich hab so viele Artikel in den letzten paar Tagen gelesen, wo immer unten drunter stand, wir haben irgendwie Apple nach Kommentaren gefragt, aber keine Antwort bisher erhalten.
Genau.
Und das ist einfach... Und da ist die Strategie, sie werden es jetzt irgendwie zwei Wochen aussitzen und weiter ihre Telefone verkaufen, als wäre nichts gewesen, Leute werden es trotzdem benutzen. Aber also warum es tatsächlich so stark in der Presse, also auch in der US-amerikanischen Presse gelandet ist, ist dieses Is-Touch-ID Hacked Yet. Das war halt irgendwie tatsächlich von zwei Security-Forschern, irgendwie aus Amerika aufgemachtes, so ein Bounty-Hunt. Also sie haben tatsächlich gesagt, da kommt dieses Produkt raus und wir glauben, dass es sicher ist, aber wir wollen mal irgendwie die Hacker-Gemeinde oder wen auch immer mal ein bisschen Anreiz vermitteln, dass da genauer aufgeguckt wird. Und sie haben halt gesagt, oder der erste hat gesagt, ich spende 500 Dollar für den ersten, der es irgendwie hackt. Hat das irgendwie in seinem Blog geschrieben, hat irgendwie ein bisschen rumgetwittert. Und dann sind halt tatsächlich innerhalb von kürzester Zeit mehrere tausend Dollar plus mehrere Flaschen gute Whisky und ein Sexheft und ein iPhone 5S zu bekommen.
Und eine Patent-Application, also eine Patentanmeldung, die ja in den USA auch nicht gerade billig ist.
Genau, es gab halt einen, der halt tatsächlich den Hack dann wirklich hätte patentieren lassen wollen. Ich hab auch kurz mit dem irgendwie getwittert und meinte irgendwie, also er hat es mir angeboten, ich hab gesagt, wir haben hier Sachen verwendet, die halt zehn Jahre bekannt sind, das ist total sinnlos, da einfach etwas zu machen. Also noch dazu, wo ich halt eh nicht so patentbeflissen bin oder begeistert von daher, also das ist halt schon mal weg gewesen. Aber sind tatsächlich wirklich, also ich hab vor noch mal nachgefragt, gut dreieinhalbtausend Euro bisher irgendwie eingegangen. Also die tatsächlich schon überwiesen wurden. Plus noch mal so was wie zehn bis 15 Bitcoins, was irgendwie auch noch mal anderthalbtausend Euro sind. Also da ist halt schon tatsächlich ganz schön viel Geld zusammengekommen und die Leute haben es tatsächlich dann auch überwiesen. Also ich meine, es war so, sie haben gesagt, dass sie es tun, aber es heißt ja dann noch nicht, dass tatsächlich irgendwie auch dann gespendet wird. Aber da ist durchaus ein bisschen Geld reingekommen.
Jetzt musst du aber natürlich auch sagen, dass du es nicht behältst.
Ja, also ich hab das Geld ganz altruistisch der Raumfahrtagentur gespendet. Das ist ein Spin-off vom CCC Berlin.
Also ein Hacker-Space.
Also ein Hacker-Space, also so ein Hacker- und Makerspace. Und die haben das auf jeden Fall nötiger und waren auch alle sehr glücklich.
Und haben ja auch ihren Anteil an dem Hack in gewisser Weise.
Genau, also ich hab auch teilweise da irgendwie dort gefilmt und irgendwie mit Leuten von dort natürlich drüber geredet.
Und zerforscht.
Auf jeden Fall gibt's da auch noch weitere Hacks, die man da irgendwie machen kann. Von daher geht das Geld schon in die richtigen Kanäle.
Aber eigentlich wollten wir darüber sprechen, warum ist Saturday Hacked jetzt sozusagen das Pressinteresse angestachelt hat.
Also es hat's auf jeden Fall halt im Vorfeld. Also normalerweise irgendwie hast du die Apple, wie heißen die diese, wir springen auf der Bühne rum.
Die Apple springen auf der Bühne rum?
Die Apple-Manager, wie heißt denn das? Keynotes, Keynotes, genau. Diese Keynote, die halt irgendwie so Produkte neu vorstellt und wo halt irgendwie dann zwei Tage ganz großer Hype ist. Aber das war halt schon im August oder wann auch immer. Und dann ist es eigentlich halt irgendwie erstmal abgeappt. Und dann wär's halt normalerweise irgendwie am Tag der Auslieferung. Also praktisch am Freitag wär's dann wieder in der Presse gewesen, das Thema. Und die haben ungefähr so zwei Wochen vorletzten Freitag halt diese Challenge aufgemacht, diese Bounty-Hand. Und das tatsächlich, also gerade in den USA, war das halt sehr groß in der Presse, weil es halt einfach irgendwie Aufmerksamkeit hat. Also halt jeder hat übers iPhone geredet, aber keiner über den Fingerabdruck oder über die Unsicherheiten. Und halt diese, wir haben hier Geld geboten für den Ersten, der es schafft. Und halt immer wieder dann kam halt irgendwie, da hat noch jemand was gespendet und da kommen jetzt irgendwie 10.000 Euro dazu. Dann gab es auch noch den Fall, dass halt der eine Großspender sich im Nachhinein als irgendwie Fake rausgestellt hat. Der hat halt versucht diese Kampagne zu übernehmen und für seine Firma zu werben. Das heißt, es ist halt tatsächlich relativ groß da irgendwie auch durch die Techpresse gegangen. Und hat das Thema wirklich halt über zwei Wochen bis zum Release irgendwie einfach am Kochen gehalten.
Ja, aber natürlich ist das nicht der Antrieb. Also der Antrieb, also von unserer Seite ist natürlich irgendwie immer schon gewesen, sind die Behauptungen, die bei dieser ganzen Werbe und dieser ganzen Marketing Kampagne, die ja so gebracht werden, sind die wahr? Kann man das mit der Technik belegen oder falsifizieren? Und dann natürlich auch, also reine technische Interesse zu gucken, haben die da wirklich einen neuen coolen Shiny Sensor hingebaut oder ist das doch bloß wieder ein alter Wagen in neuen Schläuchen?
Für uns war das tatsächlich irgendwie total irrelevant. Und als am Sonntag vieles irgendwie rausgebracht haben, hab ich natürlich irgendwie auch Kontakt mit denen aufgenommen. Also es war auch so der Grund, warum wir das jetzt irgendwie, wir machen das jetzt und zeigen das Video. Also das erste Video, was ich gezeigt hab, war tatsächlich noch nicht das komplette. Das heißt, man hat nicht gesehen, dass ich den Fingerabdruck vom Glas abgenommen hab. Ich hab's denen halt gesagt, dass es so ist und ich das Video irgendwann nachliefere, wenn ich irgendwie mal ein bisschen Ruhe gefunden hab und das Video erst mal machen kann. Und halt da kamen viel so Gespräche zustande, die halt irgendwie meinten, ja, sie haben es aber nicht gezeigt, deswegen habt ihr nicht gewonnen. Also die Seite war auch irgendwie erst, wurde nicht gehackt. Dann maybe und haben dann irgendwann erst irgendwie später auf yes geswitcht. Und es hat mich zwischenzeitlich, ich war irgendwie richtig dolch, denke ich, weil sie hat alle davon geredet haben, du musstest uns aber beweisen, weil sonst kriegst du das Geld nicht. Und ich war so, ey Jungs, ich hab das irgendwie nicht wegen des Geldes gemacht. Ich hab's gemacht, weil es einfach irgendwie ein cooler Hack ist und lasst mich doch irgendwie in Ruhe mit dem Geld.
Zurück zur Presse.
Na, also der Aspekt, den du vorhin so erwähnt hast, dass es natürlich ein Lifestyleprodukt ist und dass es doch wahrscheinlich das erste Konsumentengerät ist, was in dieser Anzahl biometrische Sensoren für so Lifestyleprodukte anbietet, ist natürlich schon wichtig. Und auch diese Vorreiterrolle von Apple in puncto Art, wie man den Benutzer leitet, ich glaube, das hat damit schon zu tun. Und die Tatsache, dass es gleichzeitig auf mehreren Kontinenten eben zum Verkauf angeboten wurde, das ist schon so eine Melange. Und außerdem muss auch sagen, die erste Berichterstattung, die so vor allen Dingen in den USA und dann in Kanada war, die war so ein bisschen verkürzt. Muss ich schon sagen. Ja, später hat eigentlich die so ein bisschen seriösere Tech-Presse da genauere Artikel gebracht und auch so ein bisschen die Technik erklärt. Es war halt erst so ein bisschen, Hacker haben Apple zerlegt und gehackt. Später wurde dann so ein bisschen genauer.
Also es war ja auch so, dass tatsächlich unsere erste Pressemeldung, also von Sonntagabend, irgendwie halt noch auf die Fakten von Samstag basierend, also wir haben irgendwie noch von Abfotografieren und von Folien zum Hacken irgendwie berichtet.
Stimmt ja auch, aber letztlich ist also der wirklich gut funktionierende Hack, den man nachmachen sollte, wenn man es probieren will, der ist halt erst später erläutert worden.
Ich glaube das Wichtige tatsächlich für die Presse war auch einfach das Video zu sehen, wie es gemacht wurde. Und halt irgendwie nur so das Video mit irgendwie da so ein Typ oder so ein Finger, so eine Hand zu sehen, die halt irgendwie einmal sich auf den Finger legt, eine Trappe auf dem anderen Finger legt und rauftrückt. Das ist halt irgendwie nichts, was man jetzt halt toll ausschlachten kann.
Aber trotzdem ist ja natürlich die spannende Frage. Also es gibt ja zum Beispiel, wer hat schon Fingerabdrucks in seinen Laptops? Lenovo?
Ja, die Lenovo hat gibt ein paar mehr.
Aber Lenovo ist ja so eine Marke, die ist auch so als Business Laptop verschrieben. Das heißt, das wird im wichtigen Bereich genutzt. Und da wäre doch genau dasselbe möglich gewesen. Also was ist jetzt sozusagen, warum ist es genau das jetzt?
Ich glaube es ist tatsächlich Apple. Also weil Apple halt schon so ein, irgendwie alle geifern drauf, wenn halt neue Apple-Produkte, also gerade wenn diese Keynote ist, also ich kenne es ja auch von ein paar Leuten so aus dem Club, die dann irgendwie gemeinsam vor den Notebooks sitzen und irgendwie sich freuen, was jetzt irgendwie neu in iOS 7 ist.
Ja, Apple hat halt eine besonders loyaler Anhängerschaft. Sich auch in Ruhe verarbeitet, glaube ich, durch viele innovative Produkte. Also wir brauchen ja wohl ein iPod, iPad und so. Aber ich glaube dazu kommt noch so ein Element. Also mein Eindruck ist so, diese starke Werbung, wenn man sich jetzt mal ansieht, wie sie präsentiert haben, hat glaube ich auch damit zu tun. Das wurde eben als zentrale Feature an diesem neuen... Es gibt noch einen dritten Aspekt, der der Mobiltelefonmarkt, gerade bei Smartphones, ist halt derzeit einfach sehr umkämpft. Wenn man sich so sammelsungen, dann die Nokia-Berichterstattung, Blackberry, da ist halt gerade, da gucken halt alle drauf, weil das eben auch ein wichtiger ähm, also zum Beispiel ein Unternehmen, ein wichtiger finanzieller Marktanteil ist.
Bei den Notebook war es halt so, da guckt man halt eher drauf, oh der hat eine große Platte drinnen, der hat einen schnellen Prozessor drinnen. Bei dem iPhone, jetzt bei dem iPhone 5S, war es halt einfach so gewesen, das ist das zentrale Feature von diesem neuen Telefon, was irgendwie halt alle, wo alle drauf anspringen.
Tatsächlich gab es ja auch einen Knick im Aktienkurs, wo wir doch so ein bisschen gefeixt haben, der sehr sichtbar ist.
Meint ihr, dass es damit zu tun hat?
Zumindest hat die Presse das so berichtet. Also natürlich, also die Angst ist sicherlich schon da, dass wenn man an einem Produkt, was man gerade mit hohem Aufwand weltweit launst und natürlich auch verkaufen will und wo auch die Wirtschaftspresse natürlich guckt, wie verkauft sich in den ersten Tagen eine Rolle spielt, wenn da plötzlich ein zentrales Feature stark kritisiert wird. Aber letztlich an den Verkaufen, das kann man ja sehen, er hat kaum, also da sieht man keinen Effekt und das ist glaube ich auch nicht unbedingt angemessen, weil schon diese Convenience, diese Bequemlichkeit beim Benutzen im Vordergrund steht und nicht so sehr die Sicherheit und wir wollten ja eigentlich auch auf grundsätzliche Probleme hinweisen und nicht unbedingt das Produkt an sich matig machen, sondern auf diese falsche Sicherheitsversprechen hinweisen.
Also von uns aus ging es auch gar nicht und im Hype ging es darauf, irgendwie wir haben es halt gemacht, weil es irgendwie da war, weil man es machen konnte und haben natürlich die Gelegenheit genutzt, halt nochmal auf die grundsätzlichen Probleme von Bimetrie hinzuweisen. Was durchaus jetzt bei Smartphones halt, also ich halte es schon für einen wichtigen Faktor, weil halt Smartphones einfach deutlich wichtiger im zukünftigen Leben sein werden. Also die nehmen halt so den Computer langsam laufen in den Rang ab. Das heißt, du hast halt wirklich sehr wichtige Daten auch auf deinem Telefon gespeichert und schützt es im Zweifelsfall wirklich entweder gar nicht. Also es hat ja Apple auch gesagt, dass was 40% der Apple Benutzer gar keinen Passcode haben. Für die ist natürlich ein Fingerabdruck halt schon mal einen Schritt in die richtige Richtung. Aber man muss sich einfach mal vor Augen führen, was dort für wichtige Daten auf den Telefon drauf sind. Und die schützt man mit halt so einem Merkmal, was halt tatsächlich überall hinterlassen wird. Das ist halt schon deutlich kritisch.
Das möchte ich an dieser Stelle mal festhalten. Also du sagst tatsächlich sozusagen, ihr wolltet zwar zeigen, dass das angreifbar ist, aber es ist besser als gar nicht zu sichern.
Also man muss sich auf jeden Fall, also wenn man halt gar nicht sichert, dann weiß man, dass es gar nicht gesichert ist. Wenn man halt Apple mit ihrer Werbung vertraut hätte, denkt man, oh das ist total hochsicher. Das heißt irgendwie falsche Sicherheit ist natürlich auch nicht gut. Aber so aus Angreifersicht ist natürlich alles, was du halt machen musst. Ich meine, der Prozess ist zwar jetzt durchaus einfach, aber ich meine, du musst halt schon Aufwand treiben, um ihn durchzuführen. Anders als halt gar kein Passcode zu haben, ist es halt schon zusätzlicher Aufwand. Das heißt irgendwie ist es durchaus für die Leute sicherer, wenn sie halt, statt gar kein Passcode zu haben, einen Fingerabdruck benutzen.
Das ist eine sehr interessante Stelle gerade, weil wenn man die Diskussion in der Öffentlichkeit verfolgt, ist es ja oft so, dass es die zwei Lager gibt, wo die einen halt sagen so, was? Nein, Fingerabdruck ist doch das Haarl Super und die Rettung der Welt und die anderen sagen so, nein, Fingerabdruck ist für gar nichts zu gebrauchen und ich möchte hier auch mal auf die reflektierten Zwischentöne achten. Glaubt ihr denn, dass die, dass tatsächlich das größere Ziel sind mit Biometrie zu beschäftigen, jetzt auch kommen wird durch diese News oder glaubt ihr, dass es jetzt sozusagen so eine Hype News und dann in zwei Wochen ist wieder alles vorbei und beim nächsten großen Gerät muss man dann nochmal von vorne anfangen zu erklären, was Fingerabdrücke eigentlich bedeuten.
Na, ich denke schon, dass grundsätzliche Zweifel an der Biometrie so als Sicherheitstechnik, die sind sicherlich gepflanzt. Die sind natürlich auch schon vorher gepflanzt worden.
Also ich glaube tatsächlich, dass der Hacks selber gar nicht so sehr zur kritischen Betrachtungsweise beigetragen hat, sondern tatsächlich eher so dieser Snowden NSA schickt Apple die Finger, drückt direkt an die NSA Vermutungen.
Sollte man die irgendwo hinterlegen.
Also das ist tatsächlich halt deutlich wichtiger in dem Fall.
Und dann, also wir hatten in der Pressemitteilung nochmal so einen Hinweis, dass man natürlich im Vergleich mit dem Passwort sehr viel leichter gezwungen sein kann, diese biometrische Merkmal abzugeben. Trägt man halt bei sich.
Also das war in Amerika gerade irgendwie, was ist das, First Amendment oder so was? Also dass du halt das Recht hast, dich nicht selbst zu belasten, also das gilt ja auch in Deutschland, und halt beim Passcode, also du kannst halt niemanden zwingen, den Passcode einzugeben, du kannst immer behaupten, ich hab ihn vergessen und sie können dir halt nicht das Gegenteil beweisen. Wohingegen halt deinen Finger irgendwie zu nehmen und das Telefon ranzuhalten, irgendwie da kann man halt nicht wirklich viel gegen tun. Also da gibt's so ein cooles Bild von so einem Mädchen, dass irgendwie das Telefon irgendwie von ihrem Dad irgendwie an den Finger hält, während er schläft, das ist irgendwie wirklich sehr süß. Und das zeigt halt wirklich sehr, sehr gut die Problematik. Und das ist halt viel schlimmer, als es kann gehackt werden und tatsächlich so es gibt halt keine Möglichkeit zu verhindern, dass es jemand gegen dich verwendet.
Na und du kannst das auch nicht austauschen. Also ich meine, dein Finger abdruckklebt an dir, das ist ein Körpermerkmal, wäre nur natürlich ein Passcode, wenn du ihn außerhalb jemand anderes bekannt gibst oder auch gerne möchtest, weil du ihm vielleicht aus irgendeinem Grund so ein Telefon mal geben musst. Du kannst das nicht austauschen. Und du hast, weil du einfach ein Mensch bist und Dinge anfasst, natürlich dauernd diese Latenzabdrücke, die du an Türen, Fenstern, Gläsern, Tassen, das ist nun mal so. Und dann auch noch direkt auf dem iPhone, wo du ja eben nur mal drauftatscht und da sind die halt auch zu Dutzenden drauf. Also das ist im Prinzip eine doofe Idee. Wir raten definitiv dazu, ein Passwort zu nehmen.
Jetzt ist ja, ich hab einen Blogartikel gelesen, hat jemand vorgeschlagen, dass man das so zweiteilig macht, also dass man sozusagen fürs einfache Freischalten und Benutzen des Telefons den Fingerabdruck nimmt, weil es ist halt einfach super bequem. Und dann aber für alles, was irgendwie mit Änderungen zu tun hat oder man kann es vielleicht auch einstellen, da wird dann doch ein Passcode verwendet. Haltet ihr sowas für gut oder sagt ihr, Fingerabdruck ist einfach so doof, dass man sie lieber besser gar nicht benutzen sollte.
Wie gesagt, also hab ich ja vorhin schon mal angedeutet, es hängt halt davon ab, was für Daten tatsächlich geschützt werden damit. Und ich geh davon aus, dass auf dem Telefon heutzutage so viele wirklich wichtige persönliche Daten drauf sind, dass ich dem Fingerabdruck einfach nicht anvertrauen würde.
Okay, also Fingerabdruck ist für euch sowas, wenn man irgendwie im Badeboiler die Wassertemperatur für alle Familienmitglieder abspeichert, dann kann man das gerne per Fingerabdruck machen. Also so Convenience-Sachen. Aber sobald es um wirklich persönliche Daten geht, ist ein Fingerabdruck eigentlich immer eine schlechte Idee.
Naja, immer noch voraussetzt, man benutzt ein Passwort. Für die Leute, die das vorher gar nicht gesichert haben, die sollen mal schön ihr Passwort...
Die sollen auch ein Passwort benutzen. Ich mein, jeder wird sich einen scheiß vierstelligen Code merken können.
Inwiefern ist denn eigentlich ein vierstelliger Code wirklich sicherer als ein Fingerabdruck?
Den lässt du halt nirgendwo. Also du kannst auf jeden Fall tatsächlich darauf aufpassen, dass halt keiner den weiß. Das heißt irgendwie, da muss man entweder dich foltern, um ihn rauszufinden oder was auch immer tun. Beim Fingerabdruck kannst du es halt einfach nicht, also definitiv nicht verhindern. Es gibt halt so Tipps wie benutzen, den hinterlässt du nirgendwo. Aber wenn du halt tatsächlich einer Person, also auf dieses Telefon von einer Person gezielt irgendwie Angriffe fahren willst, dann findest du Möglichkeiten, den Fingerabdruck zu bekommen. Du kannst auch Fotos von Fingerabdrücken nehmen und so weiter. Also es geht auf jeden Fall alles.
Ich möchte bei dieser Gelegenheit darauf hinweisen, dass auch andere hautähnliche Körperteile für diesen Sensor benutzbar sind.
Ich möchte das an dieser Stelle nicht weiter ausführen und auf die nächste halbe Stunde verweisen, wo wir nochmal ein bisschen über das breitere Thema Biometrie reden werden. Jetzt gibt es erstmal die Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr. Dann sind wir gleich wieder für euch da. Dann könnt ihr, wenn ihr Fragen habt, auch gerne nochmal anrufen unter 033 177 97 110.
Nach drei Jahren melden sie sich mit ihrem dritten Studioalbum zurück. Und zwar live und am 3.
Fritz präsentiert.
MGMT nach drei Jahren mit ihrem 3. Album live und am 3.
Oktober.
Präsentiert von Fritz.
Immer gute neue Musik.
Mit Mario Barsch.
In der CDU-Führung werden Steuererhöhungen als Angebot an einen künftigen Koalitionspartner ausgeschlossen. Generalsekretär Gröhe stellte klar, dass der Spitzensteuersatz nicht verhandelbar sei. Berichte, wonach er seine Erhöhung, eine Erhöhung des Steuersatzes als mögliches Zugeständnis an SPD und Grüne genannt habe, seien falsch. Ähnlich äußerte sich auch Unionsfraktionschef Kauder. Steuererhöhungen seien aus gutem Grund im Regierungsprogramm von CDU und CSU nicht vorgesehen. Darin werde sich auch nichts ändern. Ein erhöhter Spitzensteuersatz für besser Verdienende war ein zentrales Wahlkampfthema von SPD und Grünen. In der EU müssen Bahngesellschaften ihre Fahrgäste bei größeren Verspätungen auch dann entschädigen, wenn höhere Gewalt der Grund ist. Der Europäische Gerichtshof in Luxemburg entschied, dass die Entschädigung nicht unter Verweis auf Ereignisse wie Unwetter, Erdrutsche oder Streiks verweigert werden darf. Reisende haben demnach je nach Verspätung Anspruch darauf, dass der Fahrpreis bis zu 50% erstattet werden kann. Die Deutsche Bahn begrüßte die Luxemburger Entscheidung. Damit sei Rechtssicherheit geschaffen worden, hieß es. Man werde das Urteil unverzüglich umsetzen. Die Negativschlagzeilen rund um die Fußball-WM 2022 in Katar reißen nicht ab. Laut Recherchen der englischen Tageszeitung Guardian sind zwischen Juni und August insgesamt 44 nepalesische Gastarbeiter auf den WM-Baustellen wegen Herzversagens oder bei Arbeitsunfällen gestorben. Die vielen Todesfälle gingen vor allem auf die katastrophalen Bedingungen zurück, wie Zwangsarbeit bei Temperaturen von 50 Grad, die Verweigerung von Trinkwasser und die unhygienischen Bedingungen in den überfüllten Unterkünften. Der Weltfußballverband FIFA kündigte an, die Verantwortlichen in Katar zu kontaktieren. Der ehemalige Präsident des westafrikanischen Landes Liberia, Taylor, ist endgültig zu 50 Jahren Haft verurteilt worden. Ein UN-Sondertribunal sah es als erwiesen an, dass Taylor Rebellen im Nachbarland Sierra Leone zu Kriegsverbrechen angestiftet und unterstützt hat. Konkret geht es um tausendfachen Mord, Folter und Vergewaltigung. Taylor hatte die Rebellen von 1998 bis 2001 mit Waffen beliefert und dafür Diamanten bekommen. Die aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin Köpenick 4, in Charlottenburg 7 Grad. Cottbus meldet 5, Falkensee, Bad Freienwalde und Wiesenburg melden 6 Grad. Heute Nacht ist es meist locker bewölkt und trocken, die Temperaturen sinken auf 5 bis 1 Grad. Am Tag ist es dann meist heiter und sonnig, nur im Norden kann es auch mal einen Schauer geben, bei maximal 12 bis 15 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin A 100, Stadtring Richtung Süden zwischen Spandauer Damm und Messe Damm stockt es derzeit. Steglitz, der Abzweig Steglitz, ist zwischen Schildhornstraße und Mecklenburgische Straße gesperrt. Dort gibt es Straßenschäden. Tiergarten, wegen der Vorbereitung zum Berlin-Marathon am Wochenende ist die Straße des 17. Juni zwischen Lietzer Grabinstraße und Brandenburger Tor gesperrt. Ab 6 Uhr früh wird die Vollspörung bis zum großen Stern erweitert. Nach Brandenburg B 5 nauen Richtung Küritz, zwischen dem Kreisverkehr Briesen und dem Kreisverkehr Friesak gab es einen Unfall, die rechte Spur ist gesperrt. Und noch zur S-Bahn. Zwischen Marienfelde und Priesterweg gibt es bis Betriebsschluss Ersatzverkehr mit Bussen. Ab 4 Uhr früh werden die Züge der S1 von und nach Oranienburg ab Bornholmer Straße über Blankenburg nach Hohen Neuen Dorf umgeleitet. Wo es geht, gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW. Heute Chaosradio im Blue Moon an der Moderation Markus Richter und begrüßt herzlich noch mal seine Gäste Starbuck und Frau Doktor Constanze Kurz. Hallo und guten Abend. Es geht um einen Fingerabdruck. Es geht um mehrere Fingerabdrücke. Es geht um Fingerabdruckscanner, die man hacken kann und um Biometrie im Allgemeinen. Das jetzt. Wir haben in der ersten Stunde geklärt, wie es technisch geht, dass man Fingerabdrücke nachbildet und somit einen Fingerabdruckscanner überlistet. In der letzten halben Stunde haben wir ein bisschen über die Presse, über den Widerhall in der Gesellschaft geredet und wollen jetzt noch mal generell ein bisschen über Biometrie reden, weil dieses neue Lifestyleprodukt, was jetzt für die große Aufregung gesorgt hat, ist ja nicht das Einzige. Biometrie beschäftigt uns ja auch in anderen Bereichen und am ehesten hat man es wohl gehört, bei Personalausweis und Reisepass, wo die ja mit reinkommen, das wurde ja auch ab und zu schon mal angesprochen. Wie ist denn da jetzt der Stand gerade?
Also ich denke, über die letzten Jahre hat uns mehr so diese staatliche Biometrie sammeln beschäftigt. Einfach weil in vielen Ländern der Welt, ist ja nicht nur in Deutschland so, insbesondere für die Reisepässe, sowohl biometrische Gesichtsbild wie auch Fingerabdrücke gesammelt werden. Und auch weil in den letzten vier Jahren, drei, vier Jahren, viele Länder angefangen haben an Flughäfen die Leute zu zwingen, unabhängig von ihrem Reisepass Fingerabdrücke und auch Gesichtsbilder dort abzugeben. Da sind ja riesengroße, also millionenfache Datenbanken entstanden, besonders in den USA, aber nicht nur. In Deutschland war das, glaube ich, nicht ganz unumstritten. Also gab zumindest überhaupt eine Diskussion, sowohl als es so losging. Wir haben 2003 und 2004 schon das erste Mal damals auch mit anderen Organisationen zusammen gewarnt davor. Aber es ist ja letztlich auch eine Entscheidung gewesen, die in allen europäischen Ländern durchgezogen wurde und dann jetzt zuletzt, also es zog sich über ein paar Jahre, 2011 fing das an, dann auch am Ausweis und nicht nur am Ausweis, sondern auch an diesem Aufenthaltstitel. Also die Leute, die jetzt keine deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft haben, sondern eben nur dauerhaft in Deutschland leben, die kriegen eben auch so einen Biometrieausweis. Und da sind viele Aspekte. Wir haben schon immer auch die Sicherheit bekrittelt, aber auch qualitative Fragen, also wie gut sind eigentlich diese Sensoren? Macht es eigentlich wirklich Sinn? Ist das eigentlich eine Sicherheitstechnik? Dann aber auch die Diskriminierung. Also da gibt es eben nur mal Menschen, die können kein neutrales Gesichtsbild aufnehmen oder die haben keine Finger. Also da sind ja Probleme. Oder sie sind insbesondere mit Alter überschritten. Dann werden die Fingerabdrücke zum Beispiel qualitativ sehr viel schlechter. Warum wird das auch bei Kindern gemacht? Also da gibt es einfach sehr viele Probleme, die wir von Anfang an besprochen haben. Und dazu kam dann zwischendurch noch unsere Aktion mit dem damaligen Innenminister, wo wir den Fingerabdruck geklaut haben, um das auch nochmal öffentlich zu machen. Aber letztlich war auch sicherlich das industrielle und Wirtschaftsinteresse an dieser Technik unglaublich groß. Denn der Staat war da so ein bisschen der Initiator, dass es jetzt ein paar Jahre später in diesen Konsumentenmarkt übergeht. Und wiederum, genau wie im Prinzip früher als sogenannte Sicherheitstechnik verkauft wird, von der wir meinen, dass dort eigentlich jetzt nicht die Meere, ein Placebo, was einem da versprochen wird. Für die Bequemlichkeit mag das Hinkommen, für die Sicherheit kommt das nicht hin.
Trotzdem wird es sozusagen gefordert für Reisepässe und auch für Personalausweise. Und da hat Mona eine Frage. Hallo Mona.
Hallo.
Ich möchte mal fragen, wie das ist. Kann ich das eigentlich irgendwie umgehen? Nein, ich möchte eigentlich nicht meinen Fingerabdruck abgeben. Ich finde das eine Unverschämtheit und ich möchte es einfach nicht. Wenn ich jetzt mal auf irgendwann meinen Personalausweis beantragen muss, kann ich das irgendwie umgehen, gehen?
Also beim Personalausweis ist das tatsächlich optional. Das heißt, du kannst sagen, du möchtest den Fingerabdruck nicht abgeben. Anders ist das beim Reisepass.
Lass dich aber nicht bequatschen. Also wir haben auch gelernt, dass auf dem Melderempter bei dem Ausweisen teilweise dann so getan wird, als wenn man das müsste. Das muss man nicht. Jetzt steht natürlich auch so eine Ausweisverordnung. Man kann einfach nein sagen.
Also bei Ausweisen hast du tatsächlich die Wahl, ob du es machen willst oder nicht. Falls du irgendwann mal einen Pass brauchst, stehst du leider nicht mehr vor der Wahl, sondern da ist es tatsächlich zwangsweise verordnet.
Aber ich möchte einfach keinen Fingerabdruck abgeben und dann nehme ich einfach keinen Reisepass. Aber nur bei so einer Ausweise darf man mit Nein sagen.
Also natürlich geben wir auch Tipps und Hinweise, wie man drumherum kommt, im Meldeamt seinen Fingerabdruck abzugeben. Aber jetzt muss ich mal den Moderator angucken, ob wir das im Radio sagen dürfen.
Hier geht es ja tatsächlich. So lange du nur einen Personalsweis brauchst, kannst du einfach sagen nein und musst das auch nicht tun. Für den Reisepass ist das irgendwie noch mal was anderes. Falls du irgendwann mal in die verzweifelte Lage kommst, dann melde dich einfach noch mal bei uns. Dann können wir dir da auch helfen, dass es dann ein bisschen kommt.
Biometri-EdCCC.de ist da die Adresse. Da machen wir das auch sehr konkret. Wir haben da natürlich über die Jahre jetzt einige Versuche gestartet.
Jetzt bin ich ja nach der Ankündigung tatsächlich selber neugierig. Aber wenn ihr jetzt schon von alleine sagt, dass man das möglicherweise nicht erzählen kann.
Ich hab damit kein Problem. Ich weiß noch nicht. Also ich wollte dich nur angucken und dein Nicken sehen vorher.
Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht genau, worum es sich handelt. Wollt ihr irgendwie, dass die Leute sich die Finger in den Eierschneider halten oder was?
Würde ich nicht empfehlen. Wäre natürlich möglich, wenn man sich alle fünf, nein, man nimmt nur von vier Fingern die Abdrücke. Also die kleinen Finger. Ich möchte das einfach, einfach. Na ja gut, aber mit der Argumentation wirst du natürlich auf den Mädeamt dann nicht weiterkommen. Du musst schon, also die sind dir auf den Mädeamt dann auch verpflichtet. Dann gibt es ja noch einen Passform. Aber nicht bei meinem Personalausweis.
Solange du nur einen Personalausweis haben willst, bist du sicher und kannst erst mal beruhigt weiterschlafen.
Ja, aber beim Reisebad dann melde ich mich mal auf der Seite da.
Genau.
ccc.de Genau, einfach noch Mehl treiben. So, das war die Mona. Oder wie kannst du ja auch anders formulieren, gibt es z.B. bestimmte Berufsgruppen, die keine Fingerabdrücker haben?
ZB auch, nö, also Leute, die viel mit Chemikalien oder mit z.B. auch Bergsteiger, also Kletterer sind auch sehr ungeeignet für die Abgabe von Fingerabdrücken. Aber das ist dann tatsächlich schon was Spezielleres. Also was z.B. sehr gut hilft, ist Sekundenkleber auf die Finger zu machen und sie damit halt nicht mehr auslesbar zu machen.
Man füllt damit quasi die Rillen. Von denen wir vorhin schon sprachen.
Man muss natürlich eine gute Ausrede haben. Normalerweise, wenn man sagt, man arbeitet viel mit Chemikalien, dann kommt man in der Regel drum rum. Das heißt, dann haben sie irgendwann den Haken, der hat keine Finger bzw. keine Fingerabdrücke.
Den gibt es natürlich, weil ja Menschen keine Finger haben.
Man muss sich dann schon ausreichend doof stellen, aber es geht.
Wenn ich jetzt hinkomme und sage, Obst, ich bin gerade im Sekundenkleber gefallen.
Wenn man den Sekundenkleber aufträgt, dann ist das nicht unmittelbar sichtbar. Also es sieht so ein bisschen aus, als wenn man vielleicht, wie manche, ich weiß nicht, ob du kennst, Frisöre haben manchmal so eine Finger, wo man einfach merkt, die haben sehr viel mit ätzenden Materialien zu tun. So sieht es so ein bisschen so aus. Und auf dem Sensor sieht man eigentlich keinerlei Abdruck. Das ist dann wie so ein glattes Bild, weil man ja eben die Rillen gefüllt hat. Man muss halt ein bisschen Nerven mitbringen, weil in der Regel der Sachbearbeiter auf dem Meldeamt dann nicht zuerst sagt, na gut, dann drücke ich den keine Fingerknopf, sondern man probiert es dann nochmal, dann resetten die meistens normal den Computer, weil sie denken, der Sensor ist genau. Manchmal muss man sich die Hände waschen.
Wir hatten auch schon den Fall, dass tatsächlich jemand die Hände waschen muss. Das Gute halt dran, irgendwie Sekundenkleber hält halt relativ gut. Das heißt irgendwie auch Hände waschen. Also man kann da gerne drauf eingehen und sich kurz die Hände waschen und dann drauflegen, es wird trotzdem nicht funktionieren.
Zwei Gipsarme sind natürlich auch eine Möglichkeit. Ich habe keinen Scherz gemacht.
Was ist denn, wenn ich mir jetzt einfach auf die Zehen Fingerabdruckattrappen klebe?
Das ist eine wirklich interessante Frage.
Ist das eine Straftat oder sowas? Dokumenten?
Das müssen wir tatsächlich mal, ich kann mir das durchaus vorstellen, müsste man tatsächlich mal einen Juristen befragen. Was wir uns als Lösung überlegt haben, ist tatsächlich die Fußabdrücke, sich auf die Finger zu kleben. Weil das sind immer noch Abdrücke von deinem Körper, die aber trotzdem nicht erkannt werden können. Das heißt, da ist die Behauptung, dass es dann eventuell Dokumentenfeschung ist, vielleicht ausgehebelt, aber tatsächlich am besten mal den Juristen dazugefragt.
Tatsächlich sind die Sachbearbeiter angehalten, nach Attrappen zu gucken.
Tatsächlich?
Da sind sie sogar angewiesen. Das heißt, es gibt eine gewisse Reaktion darauf, dass wir den nun öffentlich gemacht haben. Wir kennen zumindest, also ich persönlich kenn zwei Fälle, die mit Attrappen durchkamen. Ich persönlich hab, also da wär ich glaube ich nicht mutig genug, mich dabei erwischen zu lassen, wäre mir ganz schön peinlich. Und man sieht es schon, dass man eine gute, sehr dünne Attrappe hat. Weiß nicht genau, aber wer da Nerven hat und irgendwie cool genug ist, bitteschön.
Okay, haben wir noch eine Frage von Fui, hallo?
Du hast noch eine Frage? Ja, und zwar, ich warte schon seit Ewigkeiten auf, dass das Thema wieder dran ist, weil ich hab nicht das Problem, ich bin sehbehindert und ruf gerade, ich empfindliche, muss von daher eine starke Töne drinnen tragen. Da ist ja gerade Fotos, da ist das so eine Sache. Und ich frag mich, wie soll ich das ehren, wenn man ausweist, abgelaufen ist, ich einen neuen brauche, wie soll ich denn diese geforderte Foto hinkriegen?
Du solltest auf jeden Fall als Ausnahme durchkommen. Also wenn man halt glaubhaft machen kann, zum Beispiel wenn man keine Fingerabdrücke hat, dann kann man auch einfach keine Fingerabdrücke abgeben. Genauso gut, wenn du halt tatsächlich drauf angewiesen bist, diese Brille zu tragen, können sie dir einfach nicht vorschreiben, diese Brille für ein Foto abzunehmen, das ist einfach so.
Ich meine, das haben sie mal gemacht, bei einer damals Polizeisicherheit, wo ich rufgenommen wurde. Aber eben die Nauderwei hat ja ein Problem. Ich hatte kein Auge offen, weil eben das Licht.
Also generell sind natürlich Brillenträger, es hat aber auch noch andere Aspekte, also Bartträger sind ähnlich, oder Leute mit Piercings oder Tätowierungsgesicht, die sind natürlich schon lange ein Problem. Weil natürlich, die Brille ist natürlich für so eine Gesichtserkennungssoftware ein interessantes Merkmal, wo sie dran hängen bleibt. Nun haben sie sich aber insgesamt so geeinigt, dass Brillenträger auf ihren Fotos generell, jetzt unabhängig davon, dass du sozusagen ja eigentlich nur ein anderes Problem als nur die Brille hast, die sollen die Brille aufbehalten, auch dass man mit der fotografiert wird. Natürlich darf man das in dem, wegen meiner Zeitraum von zehn Jahren, dann auch nicht ändern.
Also das zeigt halt schon eindeutig, wie sinnlos eigentlich große Teile dieser Forderungen sind.
Das heißt, wenn du deine Brille änderst, wenn die aufgenommen wird, genau.
Dann müssen wir nicht drüber diskutieren, das ist tatsächlich irgendwie...
Aber auch genau die Diskriminierung, die wir natürlich schon lange anprangern, also vor allen Dingen männliche Menschen sind ja meistens mit Bart ähnlich, die sollte man halt dann auch nicht ändern in zehn Jahren. Es ist manchmal, es ist so lächerlich eigentlich.
Okay, Free, deine Frage ist beantwortet dann?
Genau, auf jeden Fall darauf beharren, dass... Ich hab auch schon einen Fall gehabt, wo halt jemand seinen Mundwinkel nach unten verzungen hat, um halt so eine Erkrankung zu simulieren. Und hat tatsächlich auch damit durchgekommen. Also irgendwie, normalerweise darfst du ja wirklich einen neutralen Gesichtsausdruck, und er hat halt irgendwie so einen hängenden Mundwinkel emuliert. Und wenn man halt einfach nur persistent irgendwie nerft und sagt, es geht halt nicht anders, dann wird auch die Sachbearbeiterin oder Sachbearbeiter nicht sagen, aber du spielst das doch jetzt bloß, sondern du musst halt einfach nur glaubhaft sein.
Und den Chip-Tec-Prozess war irgendwie kurz wie Gruwelle, ne?
Nein, empfehlen wir nicht so, gibt einen, also gibt einen Brandfleck, man kann damit trotzdem weiter reisen, aber dann stellen sie blöde Fragen an der Grenze.
Es gibt den sogenannten RFID-Zapper, kann man relativ einfach aus einer 1D-Kamera selber bauen.
Sollte man aber nicht in der Nähe von Herzrhythmachern anwenden, wenn ich richtig informiert bin.
Ja, wahrscheinlich nicht direkt drauf falten, aber wenn du halt irgendwie nicht so bastlerisch begabt bist, kannst du auch gerne mal irgendwie im Berliner Club vorbeikommen und dann...
Ich merke, ich komme zuerst wahrscheinlich mal um den Workshop bei euch. Irgendwie nicht drumherum.
Ach, da fällt uns ein, da könnten wir gleich mal einen Termin ankündigen.
Okay, warte, weil die Zeit jetzt langsam wieder knapp wird. Vielen Dank erstmal für die Fragen. Wir verabschieden uns von dir. Bis dann. Und genau, wir machen gleich noch die Terminankündigung. Vorher wollten wir noch zwei kurze Sachen besprechen, also die eigentlich länger dauern sollten, aber es hat wieder viel zu lange gedauert. In Hamburg gab es auch irgendwas mit Fingerabdrücken an Schulen?
Ja, wir haben natürlich wahrgenommen, dass vor ein paar Wochen dann plötzlich die Lokalpresse in Hamburg berichtete, dass sie für kleine Kinder an Grundschulen, für die Essenausgabe dort biometrische Fingerabdrucksensoren einsetzen. Das ging so ein bisschen, ich glaube, das war bundesweit eigentlich nicht berichtet. Es ging so ein bisschen wie Presse. Tatsächlich ist dann auch eine Abordnung, da sind wir mal hingefahren. Wir wollten uns auch einfach mal ansehen, was die für Sensoren haben. Uns war auch nicht klar, wie klein die Kinder sind.
Also fast sechs bis sieben, acht Jahre.
So richtig kleine Kinder. Und dann aber auch Gesprächssuchen mit den Elterninitiativen und mit der Schulbehörde. Da haben wir natürlich gleich gelernt, dass wenn die Presse darüber berichtet, die auch sehr ablehnend waren, dann sind sie tatsächlich aus der Grundschule geworfen worden, obwohl wir ja nur mal einen Blick werfen wollten auf die Sensoren. Die waren da schon ziemlich gereizt. Aber die Elterninitiativen in Hamburg sind mittlerweile schon sehr aufmerksam geworden. Und die Schulbehörde, mit der wir dann auch noch mal Kontakt hatten, die sind jetzt auch nicht gerade die Biometriebefürworter. Wir gehen davon aus, dass die wahrscheinlich wieder abschaffen. Wir wollen da schon dranbleiben. Aber das ist natürlich gerade für kleine Kinder, die daran zu gewöhnen, so eine Biometrie-Sensoren zu benutzen, als wäre das eine Selbstverständlichkeit, das fanden wir doch kritisch.
Das ist ja auch der Hintergedanke bei Personalausweisen, bei den Reisepässen, tatsächlich die Bevölkerung an dieses automatische Erfassbare identifizieren von Menschen zu gewöhnen.
Jetzt, das also zu dem einen und der andere Punkt ist, ihr habt ja gesagt, so viel gewisse Anwendung ist das schon vorstellbar, also Warmwasserzubereitung und Bad für jedes einzelne Familienmitglied. Woran wird denn jetzt noch geforscht, sagen wir? Oder andersrum gefragt, welches Biometriemerkmal-Scan-Gerät wird Starbucks nächstes Jahr kaputt machen?
Also nicht erst nächstes Jahr, sondern ich habe gerade von einem Freund von mir gehört, der hat einen WN-Abdruckscanner, bei sich auf Arbeit zu stehen. Und das ist natürlich so, also wo ich bisher sage, macht es halt am meisten Sinn. Also was ich halt vorhin schon kurz angesprochen habe, halt so Merkmale, die man halt überall hinterlässt, wie Fingerabdrücke an Biergläsern oder dein Gesicht, was man halt einfach im Laufen fotografieren kann. Das ist halt denkbar ungeeignet für wirklich Sicherung von Geräten oder von Zutrittsmöglichkeiten. Die Vene, da ist es halt so, dass du dieses Venenmuster halt nicht hinterlässt.
An der Hand, also man muss sich vorstellen, dass es um die Hand geht. Hat so Handvenenmuster.
Wird da dann irgendwie ein ganz helles Licht durch?
Genau, also das funktioniert so, dass du halt mit Infrarotlicht, einer gewissen Wellenlänge halt die Hand durchstrahlst. Und halt dieses venöse Blut hat halt einen gewissen Absorbtionskoeffizienten. Das heißt irgendwie halt genau dort, wo das venöse Blut durchgießt, wird halt das Infrarotlicht aufgenommen. Das heißt, es wird dann dunkel erscheint im Bild. Und das ist halt dann auch ähnlich wie halt die Fingerabdrücke. Dann hast du halt dieses Venenmuster, was halt sehr eindeutig für einen Menschen, also für jeden Menschen sein sollte, ist halt auch noch nicht so richtig doll lang bekannt und irgendwie noch keine guten Studien dazu. Aber das prinzipiell ist das halt ein Verfahren, wo ich sagen würde, das hat durchaus Chancen, halt irgendwie sicherer zu sein als Fingerabdrücke und Gesichtserkennung, weil einfach halt dieses Merkmal nicht hinterlässt. Auf der anderen Seite muss auch klar gesagt werden, wenn du auf irgendeine Art und Weise dieses Venenmuster, also wenn du da rankommst, sei es jetzt halt dadurch, dass du das gespeicherte Merkmal irgendwie rausextrahierst aus dem Sensor oder du halt auf andere Art und Weise rankommst, wirst du auch die Möglichkeit haben, eine Art Rappe zu bauen. Also davon gehe ich halt ganz stark aus, werde ich mir dann die nächsten Wochen und Monate mal näher angucken.
Also das ist überhaupt nochmal die ganze spannende Frage bei der Biometrie, ob man das an den Stellen, wo sie gespeichert ist, nochmal auslesen kann.
Also das ist ja tatsächlich auch die Frage mit der Touch ID, also mit dem neuen iPhone, wo die Fingerabdrücke gespeichert werden, wie sie gespeichert werden, in welcher Form, wie sie gesichert sind. Auf jeden Fall nochmal ein großes Feld. Und wenn da jemand Bock hat, das zu machen, also wir haben jetzt vom Club aus ein Telefon.
Wenn das jemand auseinandernehmen will, meinst du?
Wenn jemand Bock hat, das auseinanderzunehmen, dann steht das durchaus zur Verfügung.
Aber ich glaube, er wird sich wohl meinen müssen, so wie jetzt im Wettbewerb. Also die Fragen haben sich natürlich auch schon bei dem Melderempter gestellt. Da war das zum Beispiel so, dass die Frage aufkam, ob ein Sensor, der wurde mit so einem USB-Kabel angeschlossen. Also da könnte man natürlich auch nochmal gucken, auf dem Übertragungsweg kann man die da mitschneiden. Das ist ein sinnloses Zufall dahinter.
Also ich meine, die ist einfach mal nicht sicher in dem Fall.
Also die Frage kommt mal wieder, aber ich glaube, die Spannbreite der biometrischen Erkennungssysteme ist auch deutlich weiter geworden. Also vielfach werden so sogenannte multimodalen Systeme beworben für wirkliche Sicherheitsanwendungen. Und multimodal bedeutet einfach nur, dass man mehr als ein biometrisches Merkmal nimmt. Nimmt man, weiß ich nicht, die Stimme oder die Finger ab.
Also das beste Beispiel ist tatsächlich Gesichtserkennung mit Spracherkennung. Dass du halt das Gesicht praktisch siehst, dass der Mund sich bewegt und gleichzeitig irgendwie noch ein gewisses gesprochenes Wort sagen musst.
Das funktioniert tatsächlich auch?
Das gibt's irgendwie. Also es funktioniert anscheinend nicht so gut, dass es halt gut angewendet werden kann.
Also Spracherkennung meine ich.
Also Sprechererkennung, das ist ein Unterschied.
Ja klar. Das gibt aber auch, wenn man mal über die Jahre auf die CeBIT geht und sich so ansieht, was die verschiedenen Firmen anbieten, alles Mögliche. Also man kann ja viele hundert Merkmale am menschlichen Körper vermessen, die sehr individuell sind.
Also das ist das beste Beispiel, fand ich irgendwie, Ohrform.
Ja, also Volumen des Innenohres.
Also die Schallreflektion. Sie haben tatsächlich ein Telefon genommen mit einem Mikrofon und einem, ähm, das Gegenteil. Lautsprecher? Lautsprecher. Haben mit dem Lautsprecher halt irgendwie weißes Rauschen in das Ohr reinprojiziert und haben die Rückreflektion gemessen und die ist halt auch pro Ohrform unterschiedlich. Und das ist natürlich auch ein sehr nettes Merkmal, natürlich irgendwie, wenn man halt ein Foto vom Ohr oder einen 3D-Abdruck vom Ohr macht, kann man dann auch das Ohr nachbauen, aber da gibt's halt wirklich verschiedenste.
Also man stellt sich halt einfach Ohrzugang vor, man hält dann sein Handy ans Ohr und das weißes ist das Ohr des Benutzers, so ist es gemeint. Aber der Mensch hat halt unglaublich viele solche Merkmale.
Was ist denn mit ihr, weil man es aus seinen Fiction Filmen kennt, mit Auge?
Ja, diese Irriden, wenn man jetzt versucht, Muster in den Irriden festzustellen, das gibt es natürlich auch, wurde auch schon offiziell getestet.
Also es ist sicherheitstechnisch durchaus akzeptabel. Da ist halt der Convenience-Fall komplett weg, weil es halt viel zu aufwendig ist. Du musst halt wirklich dein Auge davor halten für mehrere Sekunden. Beim Augenhintergrund leuchtet der sogar mit dem Laser rein, was halt viele Leute nicht wollen.
Was wird denn da genau gemacht?
Also Iris-Erkennung ist tatsächlich auch nur eine Kamera, also auch ein Infrarotbereich. Das heißt, du strahlst halt mit Infrarotlicht rein, machst halt ein hochauflösendes Bild von der Iris und extrahierst dann halt Merkmale, genauso wie vom Fingerabdruck, die im Minuzum extrahiert werden, machst du halt dann wieder die verschiedenen Mister auf der Iris.
Das ist ein Teil des offiziellen Tests, also da ist die Bundesrepublik tatsächlich in einem offiziellen Test, damals die Biop-2-Studie, untersucht, ob man eventuell Iris-Erkennung für die Pässe nehmen könnte.
Gibt's auch am Flughafen, also Frankfurt hat die Vielfliegerselektierung, also die Biometrie dort auch mit Iris-Erkennung gemacht. Was ich auf jeden Fall noch sagen wollte, wo es halt jetzt um Reisepässe und automatisch Abfertigung geht, also sie haben ja damals bei der Einführung immer behauptet, man kann halt zwar Fingerabdrücke faken, aber man wird sie halt niemals an Grenzen einsetzen können, weil halt immer ein Beamter daneben steht, der halt irgendwie guckt, ob dann gefaketer Finger, also eine Attrappe, drauf ist, was sie tatsächlich jetzt vor wenigen Wochen irgendwie angekündigt haben, dass sie automatische Grenzkontrollen, was wir halt schon bei der Einführung gesagt haben, sie werden irgendwann dazu übergehen, wenn sie diese Merkmal aufnehmen, ist es dafür geeignet, das automatisch durchzuführen. Und genau das wollen sie jetzt auch tun.
Andere Länder machen das sogar schon, aber bei uns ist es jetzt noch relativ neu, da haben sie ja eine Weile getestet. Und jetzt, dass diese ganze, das ganze Gerede, was sie uns am Anfang erzählt haben, das ist alles nur ein zusätzliches Merkmal, ist jetzt plötzlich dann doch wieder eine automatische Abfertigung, wo kein Mensch mehr draufguckt.
Aus der Abteilung. Wir haben es euch ja schon immer gesagt. Präsentierten wir den Chaos Computer Club zum Thema Biometrie und Fingerabdrücke. Ihr habt noch eine Ankündigung. Zwei. Noch zwei Ankündigungen.
Also der eine ist, wer sich dafür jetzt näher interessiert und vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen selber probieren will, der kann nächste Woche, und in Berlin ist, kann nächste Woche Donnerstag, also am 3. Oktober, das ist ein Feiertag, abends, wahrscheinlich so um 7 oder 8 Uhr, in den Berliner CCCB kommen. Der ist in der Mitte, in der Marienstraße 11. Da machen wir einen Datengarten und Starbuck kann da sozusagen nochmal live mit anfassen.
Ja, also ich werde halt auf jeden Fall irgendwie nicht, also den kompletten Vorgang einfach nicht, weil ätzen kann man da nicht, aber zumindest mal wird das iPhone da sein. Ich werde ein bisschen erzählen, was ich gemacht habe, ein bisschen Filme, das Video zeigen.
Haben wir da noch einen Sapper da?
Wir haben auf jeden Fall auch den Sapper da. Das heißt, wenn ihr Interesse an dem Thema habt, dann kommt einfach vorbei und wir können da gerne noch drüber diskutieren oder ihr könnt halt irgendwie auch mal ausprobieren, wie euer Finger aussieht.
Kleiner Workshop mit dem Typen, der das iPhone 5S kaputt gemacht hat. Kann man mal machen, finde ich.
Ja, man kann da durchaus was lernen und immer fragenlos werden und so. Die zweite Ankündigung, die wollen wir auf keinen Fall vergessen, ist natürlich, dass wir Ende des Jahres, nämlich vom 27. bis 30. Dezember, den 30. Chaos Communication Congress machen in Hamburg, in dem großen Kongresscenter am Bahnhof, wie heißt der Bahnhof noch? Dammtor. Wofür wir natürlich sehr gerne einladen wollen. Wir haben eine neue Rekordanzahl von Einreichungen, die derzeit durchgesehen werden und wir können jetzt schon sagen, wir werden wirklich, also wir werden ziemlich fantastische Programme haben, gemessen an den Einreichungen. Wir haben jetzt schon Schwierigkeiten, dass wir so viele Ablehnungen rausschicken müssen. Aber wir hoffen, dass wir das Programm erweitern dürfen.
Also für alle, die letztes Jahr nicht dabei gewesen sind, weil im VU ist ja nicht mehr in Berlin, es ist in Hamburg und es ist ja doof dort. Es war letztes Jahr schon cool und es wird dieses Jahr einfach total außen werden. Also kommt hin.
Also kleines Treffen am Donnerstag, großes Treffen gegen Ende des Jahres. Zwischendurch immer mal wieder, nämlich im letzten Donnerstag im Monat ein Chaosradio hier im Blue Moon. Starbuck, Frau Doktor Konstanze Kurz, vielen Dank. Wir verabschieden uns an dieser Stelle, übergeben gleich an Flo Heiler, der hier im Nullfight euch mit ein bisschen Punkmusik bewerfen wird. Mir bleibt nur noch eine Sache zusammen. Mein Name ist Markus Richter und ihr macht bitte immer schön eure Backups und lasst euch nicht überwachen.